Hey everybody, this. Hey, everybody. This is an awesome show. I think code documentation is extremely, extremely important. It gets more important as you move along in your career. So if you're just starting out, it could kind of catch you by surprise. It might seem like if you're just programming a high school project that you're turning in the next day, you might not realize how incredibly, incredibly important it is.
大家好。这是一个很棒的节目。我认为代码文档极其、极其重要。随着职业生涯的发展，它会变得越来越重要。所以如果你刚起步，它可能会让你感到意外。如果你只是在做一个第二天就要上交的高中项目，你可能不会意识到它有多么、多么重要。
But I can tell you as someone who's been programming for a long time, I go back and look at code that I've written, let's say, five years ago, and I have a bunch of documentation and it feels actually really good. It's easy to jump into it. And when I look at code that I wrote when I was a more junior engineer, I have no idea what's going on and it's a total rewrite. So I can tell you firsthand, it's extremely important. It's also very difficult to do kind of efficiently and to make it kind of part of your routine. So it's a great topic to really dive deep into and spend a lot of time talking about. And we're here with Omer Rosenbaum and Tim Post. Omer is a CTO of Swim, which is a company that really focuses on the documentation ecosystem. And Tim is the principal dev rel and user advocate for Swim.
但作为一名长期从事编程的人，我可以告诉你，当我回头看五年前写的代码时，如果我有大量的文档，感觉真的很好。很容易上手。而当我看到我作为初级工程师时写的代码，我完全不知道发生了什么，只能彻底重写。所以我可以亲身告诉你，这极其重要。要高效地完成文档工作并将其作为日常工作的一部分也非常困难。所以这是一个非常值得深入探讨和花时间讨论的话题。我们今天请到了 Omer Rosenbaum 和 Tim Post。Omer 是 Swim 的首席技术官，这是一家专注于文档生态系统的公司。Tim 是 Swim 的首席开发者关系和用户倡导者。
So thank you both for coming on the show. I really appreciate it. It's great to be here. Thank you for having us. Cool. So before we jump into it, let's talk a little bit about your backgrounds. So what is kind of your journey that led you to either found or come to swim? And what's that story like?
非常感谢你们两位来到节目中。我真的很感激。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你们邀请我们。太棒了。那么在深入探讨之前，让我们先聊聊你们的背景。是什么样的经历让你们创立或加入 Swim 的？那个故事是怎样的？
Maybe Omer, you could go first and then Tim, I'd love to hear your story as well. Yeah, sure. So my name is Omer. I'm based in Israel. And basically the first time I got a really amazing training experience was in the Israeli military. As Israelis, we go through the military. It's obligatory here. And I had a really amazing experience learning a lot in a very short period of time, how to program and many other things. And I got actually fascinated by how efficient teaching and learning can be and how much
也许 Omer 你可以先说，然后 Tim，我也很想听听你的故事。好的，没问题。我叫 Omer。我住在以色列。基本上，我第一次获得真正令人惊叹的培训体验是在以色列军队。作为以色列人，我们都要服兵役。这是强制性的。我在很短的时间内学到了很多编程知识以及其他许多东西，这对我来说是一次非常棒的经历。我实际上被教学和学习的高效性以及它所能产生的影响所吸引。
of an impact it could have. And I also got to teach a lot and train people in various places, one of them in a program called Israel Tech Challenge. And I also got to lead a security academy by Checkpoint and to train a lot of people in many places. And then I got to see them many times when they succeed and also when they struggle, when they get into new positions. And they always shared with me the experience of onboarding at first to their new jobs and being thrown
我也在很多地方教过书和培训过人，其中之一是一个叫“以色列科技挑战”（Israel Tech Challenge）的项目。我还领导过 Checkpoint 的安全学院，并在许多地方培训过很多人。我经常看到他们成功的时候，也看到他们挣扎的时候，特别是在他们进入新职位时。他们总是与我分享他们刚入职时的经历，被扔进
into the deep end of the pool, people telling them, okay, you need to get going really fast, learn a lot, really fast. And ever since then, I always had that in mind that someone needs to tackle that pain of people trying to get familiar with code bases really fast and really efficiently. Yeah. So just to unpack that a little bit, I have a friend who's from South Korea and they also have, I believe it's a year or two years of military service. And, you know, I guess, you know, as someone who, you know, I grew up over here, we're in the US where, you know, we all have that. I always thought that that was kind of like they teach you how to hold a weapon
深水区，人们告诉他们，好吧，你需要快速上手，快速学习很多东西。从那时起，我就一直记着，有人需要解决人们试图快速高效地熟悉代码库的这种痛苦。是的。为了深入探讨一下，我有一个来自韩国的朋友，我相信他们也有两年左右的兵役。你知道，作为一个在美国长大的人，我们没有那种经历。我一直以为他们只是教你如何拿武器，
and they teach you and you kind of walk a post and you peel potatoes or like just stuff like that. But it's actually really interesting to hear that, you know, as part of this service, you could do a lot of really cool tech stuff. And so, yeah, can you dive into that a little bit? Because that's something I think is really fascinating. Right. I think, well, military is big.
教你站岗，或者削土豆之类的。但听到作为服役的一部分，你可以做很多非常酷的技术工作，这真的很有趣。所以，你能深入讲讲吗？因为我觉得这非常迷人。是的，我认为军队规模很大。
There are many different positions there. I was very lucky to have a meaningful technological service, I feel. And I think one of the very special things there is that the military takes people who are 18 years old, very young, without much of experience. I mean, how much experience can you get when you're 18? And they need to train you very fast and effectively. So after three and four months, you are already productive and creating a lot of value, even if you haven't had a lot of experience beforehand.
那里有很多不同的职位。我觉得我很幸运能有一次有意义的技术服役经历。我认为那里非常特别的一点是，军队接收的是 18 岁的年轻人，他们没有太多经验。我的意思是，18 岁时能有多少经验呢？他们需要非常快速有效地培训你。所以三四个月后，你已经可以高效工作并创造很多价值了，即使你之前没有太多经验。
So that is one thing that I think is very special also in the army, because they get a lot of new people all the time and people get out of the army very frequently. So there is a lot of knowledge sharing and new people coming in and going out all the time. Cool. So in Israel, is it also a year? I know for South Korea, it's a year, but what is the length for Israel? So it's three years obligatory for men and two years for women,
所以这是我认为军队中非常特别的一点，因为他们一直有大量的新人加入，而且人们离开军队的频率也很高。所以这里有大量的知识共享，新人一直在进进出出。太酷了。那么在以色列，服役也是一年吗？我知道韩国是一年，但以色列的服役期是多久？男性是强制三年，女性是两年，
place it used to be so. And for most people doing technological service, it gets longer to even five, six or more years. Ah, okay. Okay. So that is definitely more time. But yeah, you're right. I mean, for let's say three years or even two years,
以前是这样。对于大多数从事技术服务的人来说，服役时间会更长，甚至达到五年、六年或更久。啊，好的。好的。那确实时间更长。但你是对的，我的意思是，假设是三年甚至两年，
you know, if someone takes a year to ramp up, then you've lost half of the utility you can get from that person's service. So yeah, I could see that's an environment where ramping up and good documentation is really, really important. That's right. Cool. And so from that, what kind of took you into the sort of private sector? So actually, it was a bit gradual for me. And I got to go to university after the military service, as happens quite frequently also in Israel. And I got into many training programs because I really liked
如果一个人花了一年时间来适应，那么你就损失了那个人服役期间一半的效用。所以是的，我能看出那是一个适应和良好的文档非常、非常重要的环境。没错。太酷了。那么从那之后，是什么让你进入了私营部门？其实对我来说是一个渐进的过程。服完兵役后我上了大学，这在以色列也很常见。我参加了许多培训项目，因为我真的很喜欢
teaching even when I started in the army. So I was a commander of the same course that I was a student in. So I got to teach in many different programs and I got to mix hands-on experience with teaching and training experience in various places. So at first it was a bit scattered. So I taught in various programs before I started to, I decided to focus and found my own initiative, trying to really tackle the domain of documentation in general. Cool. That makes sense. And so you're kind of learning and you're, so was it more of like, when you say gradual, were you doing kind of some part-time kind of consulting or what happened that took you from the military into Swim? Did you just jump into founding a company?
教学，即使在军队时也是如此。我曾是我自己所学课程的指挥官。所以我得以在许多不同的项目中任教，并将实践经验与教学和培训经验结合起来。起初有点分散。在我决定专注于创立自己的倡议，试图真正解决文档领域的问题之前，我在各种项目中任教。太酷了。这很有道理。所以你是在学习，那么当你说是渐进的时候，你是做了一些兼职咨询，还是发生了什么让你从军队进入了 Swim？你是直接跳进去创立了一家公司吗？
Like, how did that work? Okay. So at first I was doing part-time in many training programs and one of them was called Israel Tech Challenge. It's also where I met the other three co-founders of SWIM, which is an initiative that took a lot of people who have experience from other countries than Israel mostly. And we taught them a lot of data science and computer science stuff, but also cybersecurity. And we helped them come to Israel and get incorporated with the industry in Israel.
那是怎么运作的？好的。起初我是在许多培训项目中做兼职，其中一个叫“以色列科技挑战”。这也是我遇到 SWIM 其他三位联合创始人的地方，这是一个吸收了许多来自以色列以外国家的人的倡议。我们教了他们很多数据科学和计算机科学知识，还有网络安全。我们帮助他们来到以色列并融入以色列的行业。
So my part there was to start the cybersecurity track and train a lot of people there. And I did that in other places as well, but specifically in Israel Tech Challenge, every person who went through those programs went and started a new job at one of the companies here in Israel. And then I got to see in person how many really talented people with a lot of experience who start a new job always get to feel the same challenges of starting a new position with a lot of existing code and how hard that was. And they always talked to me at first about the difference from the experience of a training program, like we held at Israel Tech Challenge, where everything was organized and we handheld them and helped them understand and learn a lot of things in a very short period of time. And then they were just asked to start and working on tasks without a lot of guidance.
我在那里的工作是启动网络安全方向并培训很多人。我在其他地方也做过，但在“以色列科技挑战”中，每个参加这些项目的人后来都在以色列的公司找到了新工作。然后我亲眼看到，许多非常有才华、经验丰富的人在开始新工作时，总是面临同样的挑战：面对大量现有代码，开始一个新职位是多么困难。他们起初总是跟我谈论这与我们在“以色列科技挑战”中举办的培训项目的体验有何不同，在那里一切都是有组织的，我们手把手教他们，帮助他们在很短的时间内理解和学习很多东西。而后来，他们只是被要求开始工作，没有任何指导。
And I kind of felt that challenge through them a lot. And then together with the other co-founders of Swim, we all worked at ITC together. I also worked at other places, but they worked at ITC most of the time. So we all got to feel that challenge So we all got to feel that challenge and we all got to feel that this is something we want to tackle together at some point. Yeah, that totally makes sense. We have this saying where I work,
我通过他们感受到了那种挑战。然后，与 Swim 的其他联合创始人一起，我们都在 ITC 工作过。我也在其他地方工作过，但他们大部分时间都在 ITC 工作。所以我们都感受到了那种挑战，我们都觉得这是我们想在某个时候共同解决的问题。是的，这完全说得通。我们工作的地方有一句俗语，
this is very common, called imposter syndrome. And it's the idea that you train, you train, you train, you take the interview, the interview asks you these really atomic questions like, you know, invert a binary tree or solve this dynamic programming problem. And you're on a whiteboard with very low resources, but it's such a narrow scope that with the right training, you can really nail the interview. And then all of a sudden it's like, okay, here's our, you know, 300 million line code base,
非常普遍，叫“冒名顶替综合症”。这是一种想法：你不断地训练，参加面试，面试官问你一些非常原子化的问题，比如，反转二叉树或解决这个动态规划问题。你在白板上，资源非常有限，但范围非常窄，只要经过正确的训练，你真的可以搞定面试。然后突然之间，就像是，好吧，这是我们公司整个代码库的 3 亿行代码，
you know, for our entire company. And here's this task that's going to take six months. And so that sort of like really agoraphobic kind of experience just jars people and makes them think, well, you know, maybe I really don't belong here. I mean, maybe, you know, this is like, you know, I, you know, I'm just totally out of my league and I'm fired. And so we call this, we call this imposter syndrome and everyone goes through it. And I think a lot of the reason why that exists, at least to the degree that it does is, is because the onboarding is just leaves a lot to be desired. And so I think even, you know, big companies have a hard time with that and have a hard time with documentation in general. And we should talk later on about how those two are kind of intertwined. But yeah, that's, that's an amazing story. Yeah. We're definitely, I'd love to dive
这是要花六个月才能完成的任务。那种广场恐惧症般的体验让人们感到不安，让他们觉得，嗯，也许我真的不属于这里。也许，你知道，我完全不在状态，我要被解雇了。所以我们称之为冒名顶替综合症，每个人都会经历。我认为它存在的原因，至少在某种程度上，是因为入职培训还有很多不足之处。所以我认为即使是大公司在这方面也很吃力，在文档方面也很吃力。我们稍后应该谈谈这两者是如何交织在一起的。但是的，那是一个了不起的故事。是的，我真的很想深入探讨
into, into some of this stuff, but first I want to hear Tim, I want to hear you talk about kind of what, you know, kind of experiences led you to DevRel and then to Swim? Hi, I'm Tim. I started out as more of a systems programmer. My first language was BASIC, and then I quickly went to C and later C++. And I really cut my teeth in it on the back end of things. Kernels, file systems, things like that interested me immensely. So I started doing a lot of that before we really had the web,
其中的一些内容，但首先我想听听 Tim，我想听你谈谈是什么经历让你进入了开发者关系，然后又加入了 Swim？嗨，我是 Tim。我最初是一名系统程序员。我的第一门语言是 BASIC，然后我很快转向了 C，后来是 C++。我确实是在后端领域磨练了自己的技能。内核、文件系统，这些东西让我非常感兴趣。所以在我们真正拥有互联网之前，我就开始做很多这方面的工作了，
sort of as we know it. I'm kind of showing my age here a little bit. But yeah, back then, I mean, Netscape was the newest and hottest thing. And we all had those GeoCities profiles with the animated under construction GIF and all that stuff. Yeah. I remember when Microsoft made Internet Explorer part of Windows and I thought, oh, Netscape is in huge trouble, but Netscape was a much better product. And then there was the whole antitrust. I mean, it was a very dramatic time. It still is. I mean, we're just now seeing the resolution of bytes that we picked 25 years ago. It's so true.
就像我们所知道的那样。我在这里稍微暴露了我的年龄。但确实，那时 Netscape 是最新、最热门的东西。我们都有那些带有动画“施工中”GIF 的 GeoCities 个人主页。是的，我记得当微软把 Internet Explorer 作为 Windows 的一部分时，我想，哦，Netscape 有大麻烦了，但 Netscape 是一个更好的产品。然后是整个反垄断案。我的意思是，那是一个非常戏剧性的时期。现在依然如此。我的意思是，我们现在才看到 25 年前我们所选择的字节的解决方案。太真实了。
But the end result is we're all getting along, which is great. But I quickly worked my way into, at the time, there was a need for people that understood the Unix philosophy, had been working with GNU and Linux since they started booting together and understood how to configure web servers and how to manage these systems. So I started gravitating toward the web hosting industry very quickly because there were tons of consulting opportunities for me there. And I started working on things like clusters, single system image clusters, where instead of having two or three servers going kaput all the time, you could use the resources of all of them. And through that endeavor and many consulting opportunities, I became known in the industry as someone that could pull projects that were
但最终的结果是我们都相处得很好，这很棒。但我很快就进入了那个领域，当时需要了解 Unix 哲学的人，需要从 GNU 和 Linux 开始启动时就一直使用它们，并了解如何配置 Web 服务器以及如何管理这些系统的人。所以我很快开始倾向于 Web 托管行业，因为那里有大量的咨询机会。我开始研究集群、单系统映像集群等东西，而不是让两三台服务器一直宕机，你可以利用它们所有的资源。通过那次努力和许多咨询机会，我在业内被称为一个能够把项目从
very late, very over budget, essentially death marches back into the black, back into the actually shipping something. Wow. Interesting. So what made you go the consulting route instead of the sort of, I guess, I don't know what the other word would be like, the joining the Microsoft route, whatever you would call that. I was fortunate in that when I was in college, in my first couple of years in college, I had a skill set that not many people had. I understood what Linux was. I knew what GNU was. I had access to BitNet at college so that I could download stuff without paying enormous long distance phone bills using a modem. At the time, it was 2400 baud. I mean industry came to me. I didn't go to it. I got hired, approached essentially out of school and I went right to work during the first dot com
严重延期、严重超支的状态，本质上是“死亡行军”，拉回正轨，真正交付产品的人。哇。有趣。那么是什么让你选择了咨询路线，而不是那种，我不知道该怎么称呼，加入微软之类的路线？我很幸运，在大学的前几年，我拥有一种很少有人具备的技能。我了解什么是 Linux。我知道什么是 GNU。我在大学里可以使用 BitNet，这样我就可以通过调制解调器下载东西，而不用支付昂贵的长途电话费。当时是 2400 波特。我的意思是行业找到了我。我没有去找它。我基本上是在学校时就被雇佣了，我直接在第一次互联网
boom. That really changed me because I never went to the route where I had to go looking for a job that early on. There was just always something else coming up, someone else that was calling me and wanted me to work on something for them. And that just eventually, like a big ball of rubber bands, turned into a career. And it just sort of happened that way. So a lot of luck, a lot of fortune, some misfortune too. There are some really shady characters in the web hosting industry even today. But a lot of it was really positive. Unfortunately, due to the type of projects I was working on in the state that they were in, it was always a very high stress sort of working environment for me. Because you're inheriting something, it's already late.
繁荣时期开始工作。这真的改变了我，因为我从来没有走过那种需要那么早去找工作的路线。总是有别的事情出现，有别人打电话给我，想让我为他们做点什么。这最终就像一个巨大的橡皮筋球，变成了一份职业。事情就是这样发生的。所以有很多运气，很多机缘，也有一些不幸。即使在今天，Web 托管行业中也有一些非常阴暗的角色。但其中很多确实是非常积极的。不幸的是，由于我所从事的项目类型及其所处的状态，对我来说，这总是一个压力非常大的工作环境。因为你继承了一些东西，它已经延期了。
You're not quite sure what it does. You're not even quite sure what it's supposed to do. The scope is way far from the original. And you've got a few months where you have to pull it all back together. Yeah, I saw an article from the CTO or maybe it was the CEO of Waze. And he was talking about when they were acquired by Google. And one of the things that really surprised him was that at Waze, he would just fire people because of the environment. So maybe he needed like 10 lawyers, and now he only needs eight lawyers. And so he would just fire two lawyers and it kind of made sense. But in big companies,
你不太确定它做什么。你甚至不太确定它应该做什么。范围与最初的设想相去甚远。你只有几个月的时间，必须把一切拉回正轨。是的，我看到 Waze 的首席技术官或首席执行官写的一篇文章。他谈到他们被谷歌收购时。让他感到非常惊讶的一件事是，在 Waze，他会因为环境原因直接解雇员工。所以也许他需要 10 名律师，现在他只需要 8 名。所以他会解雇两名律师，这在某种程度上说得通。但在大公司里，
you don't really do that. People find a new thing to do at that big company if they're good. And so that was one of the things that surprised him. And so I think, yeah, that might be one of the big differences between doing consulting and joining one of these companies is that consulting, you are just contributing all the time, which is a double-edged sword, but you always have to be productive. At least that's the way I see it from someone who's never done consulting. That's my thousand-foot view of it. It is. It's weird in that, well, it depends on where you are in the world too, because the term consultant has some legal ramifications too, as far as your security, your job security goes. In America, we have at
你其实不会那样做。如果员工表现出色，在大公司里他们会找到新的事情做。所以这是让他感到惊讶的事情之一。我认为，是的，这可能是从事咨询工作与加入这些公司之间的巨大差异之一，咨询工作意味着你一直在贡献，这是一把双刃剑，但你必须始终保持高效。至少对于一个从未做过咨询的人来说，我是这么看的。这是我从宏观角度的看法。确实如此。这很奇怪，因为这也取决于你身处世界的哪个位置，因为“顾问”这个词在法律层面也有一些影响，特别是在你的安全感和工作保障方面。在美国，我们有“随意雇佣”原则，我想几乎每个州都是这样，如果不是全部的话，我不确定具体情况，这并非双关语。所以本质上，我们是有福利的顾问，因为除非你有某种终身职位，否则你的身份随时可能被终止。这对组织和顾问本身都有利，取决于你想做什么。你看到很多从事咨询的人这样做，是因为他们想提升自己的技能组合。他们想充实自己的简历。
will employment and I think almost every state, if not every state, I'm not sure what the state of that is, no pun intended. So essentially we are consultants with benefits because our status can be terminated at any time unless you have some sort of tenure. That is beneficial both to the organization and potentially to the consultant, depending on what you want to do. You see a lot of people in consulting do this because they want to ramp up their skill set. They want to ramp up their resume.
他们想提升，正如我们所知，当我们参加面试时，人们真正想谈论的是你以前交付过什么？你能指出你做过什么吗？所以你想把所有这些都装进你的腰包。如果你去追求大公司，你的简历往往会变动频繁。你可能在这里待一年，然后在另一家公司获得比你现在更高的职位，在那里待两年，然后再获得更高的职位，待三年，直到你的薪酬达到你想要的水平，并且你在做你需要做的事情。咨询工作可以让你走一条更直接的路线，我发现这非常有益。而且你还有拒绝工作的能力，这也是极其有益的。
They want to ramp up, as we know, when we go into interviews, what people really want to talk about is what have you shipped before? What can you point to that you've done? So you want to get all that under your belt. If you go and you sort of court the big companies, you tend to move around a lot on your resume. So you might spend a year here and then get the position above you at another company and spend two years there and then get another position above you and spend three years there before you're up to the point where you have the compensation roughly that you want and you're working on what you need to do. Consulting, you can take a much more direct route toward that, which I found to be very beneficial. And you also have the ability to turn work down, which is also extremely beneficial.
有些项目实在太晚了，或者涉及你根本不想使用的技术。我的意思是，如果你能在整个职业生涯中追溯性地对 vb.net 说不，我相信很多人都能做到。你知道，我不是在贬低 vb.net，但我知道很多人为此挣扎。所以这确实产生了一种有趣的动态。你首先注意到的一件事是，你花了多少时间在上手上，而且不仅仅是上手，而是当你走进这样的环境时，你如何掌控你所接触的一切的广度。
There are some projects which are just way too late or involve a technology you just don't want to work with. And I mean, if you, if you could say no to vb.net throughout your whole career retroactively, I'm sure a lot of people could do that. You know, not nothing, I'm not knocking vb.net, but you know, I know a lot of people struggle with that. So it does produce an interesting dynamic. One of the things that you notice foremost is how much time you spend ramping up and not just ramping up, but just sort of owning the breadth of everything that you're walking into when you walk into something like that.
这需要几个月的时间。这些是富有成效的几个月，但不是显而易见的成效，因为你没有什么可以展示的。你还没有产出任何东西。公司往往看不到其中的价值。他们会开始说，好吧，你已经为我们咨询了一个月，但你什么都没产出。我会说，那是因为你们的文档太糟糕了，我仍然不知道任何东西是做什么的。他们说，你应该能够绕过这个问题。我说，我确实通过编写我理解你们代码库所需的文档来绕过它。而且，当你四处奔波做这件事时，这总是让人感到勉强。甚至到了这样的地步，我遇到过开发人员实际上删除了服务器上的副本，并将其作为人质，以确保他们能拿到最后的工资。
And it takes months. And these are productive months, but not visibly productive because you have nothing to show for it. You haven't produced anything yet. And companies often don't see the value in it. And they will start saying, well, you've been consulting with us for a month and you haven't produced anything. And I'd be like, well, that's because your documentation is terrible and I still don't know what anything does. And they said, you're supposed to be able to work around that. I said, and I am by producing the documentation that I need in order to understand your code base. And that has always sort of fallen on begrudgingly, I would say, as you go around and do it. And it got to the point where I've even had gigs where developers actually deleted the copy on the server and kept it as ransom to ensure they got their last paychecks.
哦，天哪。是的，你真的可以，就像是，如果你们没有这些文档，你们将什么也做不了。我知道这一点，因此，我会确保你们友好地分手。所以我经历过很多这样的情况。到了后来，我不想再接触任何没有真正文档化的东西了。我开始对软件开发本身的动态更感兴趣，而不是我正在处理的代码。那时虚拟化已经出现了。我们有了新的处理器，英特尔 VT 技术，不再需要半虚拟化了。
Oh, geez. Yeah, you can really, and it's like, if you guys don't have this documentation, you're not going to be able to do anything. And I know that, and therefore, I'm going to make sure that you part amicably. So I've been in a lot of situations. It got to the point where I didn't want to approach anything else that wasn't really documented. And I became more interested in the dynamics of software development itself rather than really the code that I was working on. It was at the point where virtualization had come along. We had new processors, Intel VT technology that could, para-virtualization wasn't needed anymore.
你基本上可以在任何其他东西上运行任何你想要的东西。而且，你知道，那些年的“死亡行军”，我只是想从中休息一下。当时，我是 Stack Overflow 上的一名民选版主。那是在 2012 年左右。我一直在 Stack Overflow 上花费大量时间回答问题，基本上就是在人们身后打扫卫生。那么你能告诉大家什么是民选版主吗？Stack Overflow 上的民选版主是社区通过民主选举选出的版主，使用单记名可转让投票制。我相信他们使用的是 MeekSTV。社区有成千上万的人投票
You could just run anything you wanted to on essentially anything else. And, you know, all those years of death marches that just, I wanted to take a break from it. So at the time, I was a elected moderator on Stack Overflow. This was back in 2012 or so. And I had been spending a considerable amount of time on Stack Overflow answering questions and basically just sweeping up after people. So can you tell everyone what an elected moderator is? An elected moderator on Stack Overflow is a moderator that the community elects through a democratic election where a single transferable vote is used. I believe they use MeekSTV. And the community comes and thousands of people vote
选出他们想要的版主。如果你足够幸运获得一个名额，那么你就会被任命。你基本上获得了与公司员工相同级别的访问权限。哦，有趣。酷。然后你被委托成为该网站的特使和版主。
on who they want the moderators to be. And if you're lucky enough to get a slot, then you're appointed. And you're given essentially the same level of access that an employee of the company is. Oh, interesting. Cool. And then you're entrusted to be an emissary and moderator of the site.
在我担任版主的过程中，我越来越深入地思考为什么这如此令人上瘾，为什么程序员如此热衷于此。所以我真的，真的，真的开始像理解开发一样去理解开发者。这确实改变了我对待日常工作的方式。最终，我实在太累了，Stack Overflow 联系了我，他们说，我们的社区团队有一个空缺。你为什么不来为我们工作呢？我做了。我成为了他们多年的社区战略总监，超过八年。那确实是我进入开发者关系（DevRel）的跳板。通过那段经历，我学到了很多。而且我也开始怀念写代码了
And as I was moderating, I grew more and more into why is this so addicting and why our program is flocking to this so much. So I really, really, really got into grokking developers as much as I did development. And that really changed the way that I was approaching my day job. Eventually, I just got so tired of it and Stack Overflow approached me and they said, we've got this opening on our community team. Why don't you come to work for us? And I did that. And I became their director of community strategy for a number of years, over almost eight years. And that was really my jump into DevRel. And through that, I learned a huge amount. And I also started missing writing code
所以现在我已经有了一点回归的感觉，我比平时更多地拿起 IDE 和编辑器，也为组织的工程方面做出了贡献。所以这就是我们需要的那种快乐空间。我处于一个很好的位置，可以满足客户的即时短期需求，而这些需求是产品尚未能够实现的。所以我真的很喜欢做这件事。但简而言之，这就是我如何进入 DevRel 以及对文档产生过度关注的过程。你还在研究文件系统吗？你一直在关注整个 RiserFS 以及后来进入内核的 ZFS 吗？你还在关注所有这些东西吗？基本上把 ext3 变成一个 git 仓库，你知道，从过去的快照中回滚文件或者
again. So now that I've kind of come full circle with that a little bit, I'm picking up the IDE and my editor a little bit more than usual and also contributing to the engineering side of the organization. So that's sort of the happy space where we need to be. And I'm in a position where I'm in a great place to fill immediate short-term needs of clients that the product hasn't yet been able to accomplish yet. So that's something that I really enjoy doing. But that's in a nutshell how I got into DevRel and also hyper-fixated on documentation. Are you still into file systems? Have you been following the whole RiserFS and then ZFS going into the kernel? And are you still on top of all of that stuff? basically turn ext3 into a git repo and you know rollback files from snapshots in the past or
无论你想做什么，在那之后我开始研究一些集群文件系统，但我没有跟上进度，我记得 RiserFS 发生了什么，那真是太悲剧了。我不知道 ZFS 进入了内核，那是我需要去了解的东西。是的，实际上还有一个类似 bitrod fs 或 brt fs 之类的东西。那个，它们两个都是。ZFS 和 BitRotFS 都有写时复制（copy on write）。所以这对人们有什么作用，就像非常快速的题外话，想象一下如果你有一个 cron 任务，每天把你的编程文件夹复制到某个地方的一个新文件夹中，比如上面有今天的日期。
whatever you wanted to do and then after that i started working on some cluster file systems but i haven't been up to speed i remember what happened with riser fs that was just tragic i did not know about zfs going into the kernel that's something i need to check out yeah actually and there there is a like a bitrod fs or brt fs something like that. That one, they're both of them. ZFS and BitRotFS have copy on write. And so what that does for people, just like really quick sidetrack, like imagine if you had, let's say, a cron job that every day took your programming folder and copied it to some new folder somewhere that had, let's say, today's date on it.
所以每天它都会创建一个，你知道，5月11日，5月12日，5月13日的文件夹。好吧，所以你最终会得到所有这些冗余数据。所以 ZFS 的聪明之处在于，当你，比如说，复制一个文件夹时，它实际上并没有复制它。它只是创建了另一个引用。所以在你的实际硬盘上，仍然只有一个副本。然后，如果你修改了其中任何一个引用，它足够聪明，会实际创建一个副本，这样你就不会同时修改两者。但这一切都是透明完成的。所以你可以非常高效地进行快照之类的操作。是的，它们非常高效。这是我第一次看到它出来时的事情之一，它是一个研究项目。我相信它来自霍普金斯存储实验室。
So every day it made a, you know, May 11th, May 12th, May 13th folder. Well, so you'd end up with all this redundant data. And so what ZFS is clever enough to do is when, if you were to, let's say, copy a folder, it doesn't actually copy it. It just creates another reference. So on your actual hard drive, there's still only one copy. And then, and then if you modify either one of those references, then it's smart enough to actually create a copy so that you're not modifying both of them. But it's all done kind of transparently. And so you can do things like snapshot really efficiently. Yeah, they're hugely efficient. That was one of the things that when I first saw that coming out, and it was a research project. I believe it came out of the Hopkins Storage Lab.
我想是 Zachary Peterson 博士实现了它。哦，有趣。我不知道。我在做网络托管，我们有所有这些，你知道，整个奔腾 4 高清服务器群在机架上托管网站。备份对我们的客户来说是一个巨大的问题。所以自然地，如果你能在文件系统层面做到这一点，并制作不可变的副本，以便你可以轻松地恢复它，我想希望能围绕它建立一个产品。所以这只是我工作过的一些事情的例子，随着整个网络开发文化在我周围成长。所以这就是我真正拥抱 DevRel 的全部，你知道，不是
I think Dr. Zachary Peterson was the one that implemented it. Oh, interesting. I didn't know that. I'm working in web hosting, and we have all of these, you know, this whole farm of Pentium 4 HDs on Baker's racks hosting websites. And backups were a huge problem for our clients. So naturally, if you could do that at the file system level and make immutable copies of stuff so that you could restore it that easily, I wanted to hopefully build an offering around that. So that was just sort of an example of some of the stuff that I worked on, sort of as the whole web development culture grew up around me. And so that was basically it as far as how I really embraced DevRel is, you know, not
纯粹是其中之一。我，你知道，两者兼有。是的，这很有道理。所以也许从头开始真的很好。我们有高中生，甚至更年轻的人。我们的观众中有很多刚起步的人。我的意思是，实际上与年龄无关，还有正在转行的人。所以对于刚入门的人来说，你知道，什么是代码文档？比如什么是好的代码
so much just purely one or the other. I'm, you know, sort of both. Yeah, that makes sense. So maybe it'd be good to really start at the beginning. We have folks who are in high school, actually even younger. We have a lot of folks in the audience who are just getting started. I mean, and actually independent of age, there's folks who are switching careers. And so for someone who's just getting into it, you know, what is code documentation? Like maybe what is good code
文档，为什么人们应该这样做？好的代码文档就是，正如你早些时候所说，任何能帮助你学习而不会触发身体对压力的最小反应的东西就是最好的。所以好的代码文档应该让你感到被支持。它应该让你在阅读过程中感到自己有所成就。它应该是强化性的。它应该是相对新且完整的。它应该是最新的。它应该是可发现的。有很多，但要让它成为这些东西中的任何一个，它首先必须存在。而通常它就是不存在。人们的学习方式不同。在任何给定的时间点，如果你雇佣 10 名开发人员，人们来到
documentation and why should people do it? Good code documentation is whatever, as you said early, very early, early on, whatever helps you learn without triggering the minimum reactions that your body has to stress is the best. So good code documentation should make you feel supported. It should make you feel as if you've accomplished something as you go through it. It should be reinforcing. It should be relatively new and complete. It should be up to date. It should be discoverable. There's a whole lot, but in order for it to be any of those things, it first has to exist. And quite often it just doesn't. People learn differently. At any given point, if you hire 10 developers, people come to
你这里，他们正在入职，在这个阶段他们非常脆弱。他们进入了新的领域，学习新的代码、新技术、新事物。他们进入了新的社交动态。他们在办公室结交新朋友并建立新的同僚关系。他们那天早上走新的路去上班。他们走新的路回家。关于你入职体验的一切对人们的影响比我认为
you and they're onboarding and they're really vulnerable at that stage. They're into something new. They're learning new code, new technologies, new things. They're into a new social dynamic. They're making new friends and establishing new peers at the office. They take new ways to go to work that morning. They take new ways to go home. Everything about your onboarding experience affects people a little bit more profoundly than I think
很多人通常意识到的要深刻得多。你的文档应该始终存在，以本质上支持他们在早期到参考事物时需要做的任何事情。而且文档，好的文档也应该在传达知识方面是有意为之的。在编程中有一个知识领域，你仅仅通过接触事物、仅仅通过接触代码、接触编写代码的人以及接触测试代码的人就能获得。这通常不是有意传达的。它只是在你完成入职体验时潜移默化地吸收了。
a lot of people relate to commonly. And your documentation should always be there to essentially support them in anything that they need to be able to do from early on to reference things. And the documentation, good documentation should also be deliberate in conveying knowledge. There's a sphere of knowledge in programming that you pick up just from being around stuff, just from being around the code and being around the people that write the code and being around the people that test the code. And this isn't often deliberately conveyed. It just sort of soaks in as you get through the onboarding experience.
我经常挑战人们去识别那些隐性知识，并使其变得非常、非常刻意，并识别人们正在学习什么。所以伟大文档的另一个重要部分是倾听，找出文档在哪些地方失败了。如果你是一名新开发人员，并且你试图找到一条信息但找不到，你需要捕捉这种摩擦并将其反馈给维护文档的人，或者如果需要，你自己创建它。而且需要很早就设定好，这就是组织将如何演变的方式。此外，文档有一个非常糟糕的内涵，因为人们认为，是的，那就是我
And I often challenge people to identify that tacit knowledge and make it very, very deliberate and identify what people are learning. So another big part of great documentation is listening to find out where the documentation failed. If you are a new developer and you are trying to find a piece of information and you can't find that, you need to capture that friction and give it back to whoever's maintaining the documentation or create it yourself if you need to. And it needs to be set out very early on that that's sort of how the organization is going to evolve. And additionally, documentation gets a really bad connotation because people are thinking, yeah, that's that thing that I have
每三个月当它再次过时时就必须从头开始重写的东西。因此，要使文档变得好，必须有一些东西推动它。它确实需要是持续的。它必须是如果它过时了，有一些方法可以让你发现。并且创建了一些问题，以便人们将其带回正轨，而 Omer 可能对此有更多要说的。当然，所以我认为首先好的文档可以帮助你理解什么是重要的。Jason，你提到当有人是新人或来到一个新地方时，基本上首先你需要在短时间内掌握很多东西。所以好的文档可以帮助你理解关注什么是重要的。
to completely rewrite from scratch every three months when it goes out of date again. And so for documentation to be good, there must be something pushing it along. It really needs to be continuous. It has to be something that if it falls out of date, there's some way that you find out about that. And some issue is created so that people bring it back up sort of into the speed and omer probably has a a whole lot more to say about that sure so i think first good documentation helps you understand what's important jason you mentioned when someone is new or coming to a new place then basically first you have a lot to grasp in a short amount of time. So good documentation helps you understand what's important to focus on.
而且它还可以帮助你理解正在进行的主要流程，以及仅仅通过开始阅读代码本身很难理解的事情。它还可以帮助你理解导致代码当前状态的过程，因为即使你阅读了整个代码库，也需要时间。它只会让你感觉到代码中当前存在什么，而不是导致它的原因。例如，动机，开发人员在整个过程中做出的所有决定。所以基本上好的文档可以帮助你非常快速地理解你需要知道的一切，以便做出有意义的贡献。是的，这很有道理。我认为你所说的大部分内容确实引起了我的共鸣。是的，我认为它是一种活的、你知道，自我修复系统的整个想法是
And also it helps you understand the main flows going on and things that are pretty much hard to understand by just starting to read perhaps the code itself. And also it helps you understand the process to lead that the current state of the code, because even if you read the entire code base, it would take time. It only gives you the sense of what currently exists in the code and not what led to it. For example, the motivation, all the decisions that developers have made throughout the time. So basically good documentation helps you get really fast into understanding everything you need to know in order to make meaningful contributions. Yeah, that makes sense. I think a lot of what you said really resonates with me. Yeah, I think the whole idea of it being kind of a living, you know, self-healing system is
被低估了，非常重要。我在想，你知道，我有两个孩子，小的那个现在刚长出全部四颗磨牙。所以他有点像个小恶魔。但我记得对于大的那个，正如大多数第一次做父母的人一样，我们试图计划好一切。然后果然，没有什么真正按计划进行。我们学到的是，真的，当你抚养孩子或构建代码库时，关键在于能够以健康的方式适应，能够反应并真正闭环。有些事情会比你预期的更好。有些事情会比你预期的更糟。能够为此做好准备并处理它，我认为这才是真正重要的。
really underrated, really important. I'm thinking about, you know, I have two kids, the younger one is just getting all four of his molars in now. And so he's a bit of a terror. But I remember that with the older one, as most first-time parents do, we tried to plan everything out. And then sure enough, nothing actually goes to plan. And what we learned was that really, when you're raising kids or when you're building a code base, it's really about being able to adapt in healthy ways and being able to react and to sort of really close the loop. And some things will go better than you expected. Some things will go worse than you expected. And being able to sort of be ready for that and handle that, I think that is actually what's really important.
所以人们进入测试和代码文档，试图制定规则。比如我想要 80% 的测试覆盖率，或者我想要，你知道，这个文件夹里的每个函数都被记录下来。我的意思是，规则很好，但实际上更重要的是你们俩都提到的，那就是能够自我修复。所以如果你的代码库中出现了一些故障，那应该变成一个测试，对吧？所以你为了修复该故障所做的任何事情都应该是测试的一部分。同样，当有人来找你并说，你知道，看，团队中没有人理解这个人三年前写的这段代码在做什么，它阻碍了每个人。好吧，那么我们不仅要重写
And so people go into, you know, testing and code documentation, trying to come up with rules. Like I want 80% test coverage, or I want, you know, every function in this folder to be documented. And I mean, the rules are fine, but actually what's even more important is what you both touched on, which is being able to self-heal. So if you have some failure in your code base, that should turn into a test, right? So like whatever you had to fix to fix that failure should be part of a test. And similarly, when someone comes to you and they say, you know, look, no one on the team understands what this code that this person wrote three years ago is doing and it's holding everyone back. Well, then not only are we going to rewrite
它，我们还要记录它，因为显然我们需要从中恢复。所以，是的，这极其重要。这实际上是关于建立正确的适应性流程。我同意。我还认为，当你阅读已经过时的文档时，因为在大多数情况下，文档不会与代码并行。所以代码在演变，而文档没有。然后有人读了它并说，好吧，这里的一切都过时了。那么那个人也应该更新文档，或者你应该部署帮助你完成该任务的工具，确保文档在代码演变时仍然与代码的当前状态相匹配。即使文档没有完全更新，如果我在入职或做某事时，对我来说说出来也非常有帮助，因为作为程序员，我们
that, we're also going to document it because clearly we need to heal from that. And so, yeah, that is extremely important. It's really about setting up the right adaptive processes. I agree. I also think that when you read through documentation that has gone out of date, because in most cases, documentation doesn't leave in parallel with the code. So the code evolves and the documentation doesn't. And then someone reads through it and says, okay, everything here is outdated. Then that person should also update the documentation, or you should deploy tools that help you with that task, that make sure that the documentation still matches the current state of the code as it evolves. Even if the documentation isn't fully updated, it's really helpful for me to say if I'm onboarding something or to doing something, because as programmers, we
...
tend to blame ourselves when things go wrong. I broke it. And that tends to happen. If you can do something that says, hey, look, the documentation that you're currently working with, we believe it to be mostly current, but examples may not line up with what you find in the code. That is a big deal for me because I am going to really stress out if I go looking, searching through the code for this
当事情出错时，我们往往会责怪自己。是我弄坏了它。这种情况经常发生。如果你能做点什么，比如，“嘿，看，你目前使用的文档我们认为基本是最新的，但示例可能与你在代码中找到的不一致。”这对我很重要，因为如果我去找代码中那个你提到的示例却找不到，我会感到非常压力。
example that you have there, and I can't find it. I'm going to think, do I have the right repo? Am I even looking at the right thing? Oh my God, how did I even get hired here? You know, that's the sort of imposter syndrome that can really start to creep into you if you don't actively try to chase it out. So even if everything isn't pristine, just some sort of indication that it's not you, it's us, very subtly in that documentation can really, really, really be helpful. Because as we know, stress is the enemy of creativity and learning. If you're stressed out, you start looking for things that you want to shut out. That is the opposite of what you should be doing.
我会想，我是不是找错仓库了？我看的到底对不对？天哪，我是怎么被录用的？你知道，如果你不主动去驱散这种冒名顶替综合症，它真的会开始潜入你的内心。所以，即使一切并不完美，在文档中非常微妙地暗示“不是你的问题，是我们的问题”，真的、真的、真的很有帮助。因为我们知道，压力是创造力和学习的敌人。如果你感到压力很大，你就会开始寻找想要拒绝的东西。这与你应该做的恰恰相反。
And we talk about onboarding as if it only happens once or twice when you join a company. If the company that you're joining has like 35 microservices running, you're going to onboard 35 times a month because those code bases are going to change drastically almost every single day. So it's not the occasional problem that it used to be when it comes to internal code. We would often complain about library code not being very well documented if it's third party. But our internal code itself, the documentation on that is much more important than I think it ever used to be.
我们谈论入职培训时，好像它只发生在你加入公司时的一两次。如果你加入的公司有 35 个微服务在运行，你每个月都要进行 35 次入职培训，因为这些代码库几乎每天都会发生剧烈变化。所以，对于内部代码来说，这不再是过去那种偶尔出现的问题了。我们经常抱怨第三方库的文档写得不好。但我们的内部代码本身，其文档的重要性我认为比以往任何时候都重要。
Right. And I think it has become much more complex in recent years in that you have many multi repos nowadays and many microservices. And sometimes you read some code and then you don't even understand what it interacts with because the code that's responsible for interacting with it lives within another repository. Or maybe it's a third-party service that is running somewhere else and you don't even know where it is or you don't even know where to look for it to get and understand what's going on behind the scenes. So as machines and systems become more and more complex,
没错。而且我认为近年来它变得更加复杂了，因为现在有很多多仓库和许多微服务。有时你读了一些代码，却根本不明白它与什么交互，因为负责与它交互的代码位于另一个仓库中。或者它可能是运行在其他地方的第三方服务，你甚至不知道它在哪里，或者不知道去哪里寻找它来了解幕后发生了什么。因此，随着机器和系统变得越来越复杂，
I think the importance of documentation is even bigger nowadays. A real world example of that is like, you want to do some sort of debugging on like this huge Java data broker service that's running somewhere. And unbeknownst to you, this thing needs like 128 gigabyte in order to run. And you tried debugging it on your laptop and you're wondering why it won't work. And you waste, you know, like two days until someone finally tells you, look, you're not actually going to be able to run that locally. Here's how you need to debug that. Having that debugging guide handy
我认为文档的重要性在今天变得更加重要。一个现实世界的例子是，你想对某个运行在某处的巨大 Java 数据代理服务进行某种调试。而你不知道的是，这个东西需要 128GB 内存才能运行。你试着在笔记本电脑上调试它，却纳闷为什么不行。你浪费了大约两天时间，直到有人最终告诉你：“看，你实际上无法在本地运行它。这是你需要调试的方法。”手头有那份调试指南
when I'm first going, just some breadcrumbs for that would be huge. And this is part of what I call the tacit knowledge, a really good example of it. If you gas up your car, you put the nozzle, you stick it in your tank, right? And then you squeeze the lever, you know where the gas is going. It's going into your gas tank. That's very deliberate. Now, the way the documentation works, if you can imagine, you just get the nozzle and you sort of squirt it on the roof of the car and you hope the gas soaks in where it needs to go somewhere. That is actually the song and dance that we make our fellow programmers do. And we really need to stop doing that because it's not fair to them and it wastes a lot of time. Right. I think in your story, Tim, actually someone on your team actually knew that you
当我第一次开始时，哪怕只是一些线索也会非常有帮助。这就是我所说的隐性知识，一个很好的例子。如果你给车加油，你把喷嘴插进油箱，对吧？然后你扣动扳机，你知道汽油去了哪里。它进入了你的油箱。这是非常明确的。现在，文档的工作方式，如果你能想象一下，你只是拿着喷嘴，把它喷在车顶上，然后希望汽油能渗进它需要去的地方。这实际上就是我们让同事们做的“歌舞表演”。我们真的需要停止这样做，因为这对他们不公平，而且浪费了很多时间。没错。我想在你的故事里，Tim，其实你们团队里有人知道你
shouldn't be using that laptop to debug that thing, right? Yeah. And someone could have stopped you from pouring gas all over your car. I mean, it's not only a waste of time, but it's also for the new person, it feels as if you really haven't considered them in the grand scheme of things of how you're going. And that's not very inclusive. It's not very welcoming. It's not what we should be doing to each other. It's a really good example of that. And the self-healing part really helps that if something comes and kicks you in the backside and says, okay, you have updated your major version in this particular file, which means you've done a big release. And we haven't looked at any of this documentation that talks about the why and the
不应该用那台笔记本电脑来调试那个东西，对吧？是的。本来有人可以阻止你把汽油浇得满车都是。我的意思是，这不仅是浪费时间，而且对于新人来说，感觉就像你在大局观上根本没有考虑过他们。这很不包容。这很不友好。这不是我们应该对彼此做的事情。这是一个很好的例子。而自我修复部分确实有帮助，如果有什么东西踢了你一脚，说：“好吧，你在这个特定文件中更新了主版本，这意味着你做了一个大版本发布。而我们还没有查看任何关于‘为什么’以及
debugging and setting up your development environment, that is part of the automation that actually has to happen. And I believe I'm a big fan of thinking that there can be true automation even when you have to depend on human beings to do things. It does actually work. Yeah, that all makes a ton of sense. So I think we talked a lot about what good documentation is and in terms of why, you know, one of the biggest reason is what we all touched on that, you know, even if you write the code and someone else, assuming you have some type of peer review process, if someone else is peer reviewing it right off the bat, twice as many people have read the code, right?
调试和设置开发环境的文档”，这就是必须发生的自动化的一部分。我相信，即使在必须依赖人类来完成某些事情的情况下，也可以实现真正的自动化。它确实有效。是的，这一切都很有道理。所以我认为我们谈了很多关于什么是好的文档，至于原因，你知道，最大的原因之一就是我们都提到的，即使是你写的代码，如果有人进行同行评审，假设你有某种同行评审流程，如果有人在第一时间进行评审，那么阅读代码的人数就增加了一倍，对吧？
Because you've read it since you're the author and the peer reviewer has read it. And it's probably going to be an order of magnitude more people have read it than have written it. And so we kind of take that for granted. We take for granted just how many people are actually going to read this code and how many times they're going to read it. And the same is true for documentation. And so this helps a lot of the insecurity and the stress that people feel when they're onboarding. Another thing which is, I think, going to become more and more important is that documentation sets up contracts between or among engineers. And now we've been working remote for over a year now. And so without being able to tap that person on the shoulder and say, hey, your function, can you also make it accept floats? Because I have some fractions I
因为你作为作者读过它，同行评审员也读过它。而且阅读它的人数可能会比编写它的人数多出一个数量级。所以我们有点想当然了。我们想当然地认为到底有多少人会阅读这段代码，以及他们会读多少次。文档也是如此。这有助于缓解人们在入职时感受到的许多不安全感和压力。另一件我认为会变得越来越重要的事情是，文档在工程师之间建立了契约。现在我们已经远程工作一年多了。所以，如果没有办法拍拍那个人的肩膀说：“嘿，你的函数，能让它也接受浮点数吗？因为我有一些分数
need to pass in. You can't do that anymore. You can IM somebody, but maybe they won't get to it until tomorrow. They won't even see your IM. And so I think it's really important going forward that we figure out a way to, especially among teams that are distributed, you know, set up contracts and documentation could be a really good way to do that. teams that are distributed, set up contracts and documentation could be a really good way to do that. It definitely can be. Absolutely can be. What's even worse in that scenario is if that got implemented like three months ago and you didn't know it and you were still doing it like the hard way. And the only thing that broke there was because it just wasn't documented that this was the new behavior yet. So it absolutely
需要传入。”你再也做不到了。你可以给某人发即时消息，但也许他们要到明天才能处理。他们甚至可能看不到你的消息。所以我认为，展望未来，我们找到一种方法非常重要，特别是在分布式团队中，建立契约，而文档可能是一个非常好的方式。分布式团队，建立契约，而文档可能是一个非常好的方式。绝对可以。绝对可以。在这种情况下更糟糕的是，如果那是三个月前实现的，而你不知道，你仍然在用那种困难的方式做。唯一出问题的地方就是因为没有记录这是新的行为。所以它绝对
needs to happen, even in organizations that are truly remote first. And by that, I mean, almost all of your critical path discussions happen in Slack or whatever you use to communicate in order to talk among each other, instead of everyone huddles over in the office and like half the people, you know, in Brazil or wherever aren't part of the conversation. And that, that can really happen in a lot of organizations, unless you're very deliberate about it. Cool. And so we should definitely talk about tools, but independent for now, just, just suspending the discussion on tools for a moment. What are general practices? Like, how do people go about writing good documentation? What is sort of like the mindset, you know, and is it something where it's totally in the code? Like how do you reconcile your code versus
需要发生，即使是在真正远程优先的组织中。我的意思是，你几乎所有的关键路径讨论都发生在 Slack 或你用来交流的任何工具中，而不是每个人都在办公室里挤在一起，而一半在巴西或其他地方的人没有参与对话。除非你非常刻意地去做，否则这在很多组织中真的会发生。酷。所以我们肯定应该谈谈工具，但现在先不谈，暂时搁置关于工具的讨论。什么是通用实践？人们是如何编写好的文档的？心态是什么样的，它是完全在代码里的吗？你如何协调你的代码与
a wiki versus your 10 other media? You know, what are good practices there? I think the biggest one is when you write it. I get asked that a lot, like, when should I write my documentation? And it uh like well as soon as the thing that you're working on starts looking you know it's taken a similar shape a few times you've solidified the code you solidified the behavior you've got you know pretty much everything mapped out at that point you should really start to write documentation because documentation that i write about for i'm right now, I'm writing a command line tool in Python. So as soon as before I released this, I'm going to make sure that it
维基或你的其他 10 种媒介？你知道，那里有什么好的做法吗？我认为最重要的一点是编写的时间。我经常被问到这个问题，比如，“我应该什么时候写文档？”嗯，就像当你正在做的事情开始看起来……你知道，它已经几次呈现出相似的形状，你已经固化了代码，固化了行为，你已经把几乎所有东西都规划好了，在那一点上，你真的应该开始写文档了。因为我正在写的文档，我现在正在用 Python 写一个命令行工具。所以在我发布它之前，我要确保它
has a nice help section and that the code in my flow is documented there. If I write that documentation in two days, when I released this thing, it's going to be good. Everything that I was thinking top of mind is going to be in that documentation. And for my future self, who you identified very early on, when we started talking, there's going to be reminders there of everything that I was thinking at the time. And it is going to be thus higher quality than anything I could write three months from now, bar none. Even if I'm the same person, I wrote the same tool, my documentation for it is always going to be better when it's fresh in mind. So whatever flow that you adopt, it should be centered on basically writing it when it's fresh. If you don't do that, number one, it's not as good.
有一个很好的帮助部分，并且我流程中的代码在那里有文档记录。如果我在两天内写好那份文档，当我发布这个东西时，它会很好。我当时脑子里想的一切都会在那份文档中。对于未来的我，正如我们在谈话开始时很早就指出的那样，那里会有我当时所想的一切的提醒。因此，它的质量将比我三个月后能写的任何东西都要高，毫无疑问。即使我是同一个人，我写了同一个工具，当它在脑海中还很新鲜时，我的文档总是会更好。所以无论你采用什么流程，它都应该以在新鲜时编写为中心。如果你不这样做，第一，它没那么好。
And number two, if you can justify procrastinating and not writing it today, then you will also be able to justify procrastinating and not writing it tomorrow. And then the next thing you know, it's three months from now and you're facing another sprint to go write about your documentation about stuff that you don't really remember. Yep. I have another rule that I follow, which is if I see something that an elementary coder wouldn't understand that I asked that there's some documentation next to that. So for example, you know, we write most mostly in Python and in Python, there's this thing you can do. There are these, I forgot what the name of it is. It's the functions that have the underscores in the beginning. There's a term for all of those.
第二，如果你能为拖延而不写它找到理由，那么你明天也能为拖延而不写它找到理由。然后你会发现，三个月后，你又面临着另一场冲刺，去写关于你并不真正记得的东西的文档。是的。我遵循的另一个规则是，如果我看到一些初级程序员看不懂的东西，我会要求在旁边写一些文档。例如，你知道，我们主要用 Python 编写，在 Python 中，你可以做这件事。有这些东西，我忘了它的名字是什么了。它是那些开头有下划线的函数。所有这些都有一个术语。
The most common one is underscore, underscore, init, right? But there's other ones. In this case, it's underscore, underscore, get atter. And you can use this. So if you have a object in Python, like foo, you can actually call like foo.x, foo.y, foo.z, even if these aren't members of your class. And if they're missing, it will call this function. And so you could effectively do foo.anything and it will actually, it won't, it will, it will do something. It will go into that function and something will happen. And so- Overloading. Yeah. Yeah. And so I think it's all like magic methods or something, that whole category, like underscore, underscore, EQ
最常见的是 `__init__`，对吧？但还有其他的。在这种情况下，它是 `__getattr__`。你可以使用它。所以如果你在 Python 中有一个对象，比如 `foo`，你实际上可以调用 `foo.x`，`foo.y`，`foo.z`，即使它们不是你类的成员。如果它们缺失，它会调用这个函数。所以你可以有效地做 `foo.anything`，它实际上会……它会做点什么。它会进入那个函数，然后发生一些事情。所以——重载。是的。是的。所以我认为这就像魔术方法之类的，整个类别，比如 `__eq__`
and all of that. But someone used that and I just said, hey, can we just document why we're using that? Because it's going to add cognitive overhead, right? And so in this case, it had to do with overloading a class that we didn't own. And so there's a good reason to do it. But anytime you have to do something that is, you know, starting to get into the more advanced
等等。但有人用了那个，我就说：“嘿，我们能记录一下为什么我们要用它吗？”因为它会增加认知负担，对吧？所以在这个例子中，它与重载一个我们不拥有的类有关。所以有一个很好的理由这样做。但任何时候你必须做一些……你知道，开始进入更高级的
parts of the language, that's where I really, you should have really high density of documentation on day one, like right when the code goes in. And so I've had cases where right when the code went in, there's some comment saying, you know, yeah, you know, we're dividing by this magic number because it's faster than square root. Like that needs a comment because you'll look back and you'll say, you know, why am I dividing by 67,000?
语言部分的事情时，那就是你应该在第一天就有高密度文档的地方，就在代码进入的时候。所以我遇到过这样的情况，就在代码进入时，有一些注释说：“你知道，是的，我们在除以这个魔数，因为它比平方根快。”这需要一个注释，因为你会回头看，然后说：“你知道，我为什么要除以 67,000？”
Like it doesn't be in a function called square root, right? Right, exactly. And so, yeah, I think some code, and you'll know right away, some code needs to be documented, you know, zero day. And then to your point, as soon as you start kind of having the whole idea, then you could really kind of document everything else too.
它不需要在一个叫平方根的函数里，对吧？对，完全正确。所以，是的，我认为有些代码，你会立刻知道，有些代码需要被记录，零日记录。然后正如你所说，一旦你开始有了整个想法，那么你也可以真正地记录其他所有东西。
You just said trick something that I think is really good to bring to light. Coming back to sort of the imposter syndrome thing, a lot of engineers that I know would not ask questions about that. They would just say, oh, that's how you do it. It seems really weird to me, but I don't know enough to say that this is not right or even questionable. And therefore, I'm not even going to say anything about it. And then it's going to trip up the next 15 people that hit it. Right. And I think, Jason, that's a great example of where inline comments, comments in your code, are actually the right way to go. You have a specific line that does something like dividing a number by 67,000, and no one is probably going to know
你刚才说的话触发了一些我认为非常值得拿出来讨论的事情。回到冒名顶替综合症的事情上，我认识的很多工程师不会问关于那个的问题。他们只会说：“哦，原来是这样做的。这对我来说看起来真的很奇怪，但我知道的不够多，不能说这是不对的，甚至是有问题的。”因此，我甚至不会对此说任何话。然后它会绊倒接下来的 15 个遇到它的人。没错。而且我认为，Jason，这是一个很好的例子，说明内联注释，即代码中的注释，实际上是正确的做法。你有一行特定的代码，做了一些像除以 67,000 这样的事情，可能没有人会知道
why you did that at that time, so you're going to add inline what's going on. This is the kind of things that you want to document inline within the code. I think for other cases, like flows between different code files, between different functions, or nowadays between different repositories,
为什么你在那个时候那样做，所以你要在内联中添加正在发生的事情。这就是你想要在代码中内联记录的事情。我认为对于其他情况，比如不同代码文件之间、不同函数之间，或者现在不同仓库之间的流程，
what you want to do is document not within the code itself, but in external documents that may reside within the code base, but still not next to the code lines themselves. However, people tend to approach those documents in a way that's more literal. So they would just write a lot of text
你想要做的不是在代码本身内记录，而是在外部文档中记录，这些文档可能驻留在代码库中，但仍然不在代码行旁边。然而，人们倾向于以更字面的方式处理这些文档。所以他们只会写很多文字，
and then it's also hard for them to start writing because they don't even know where to start. And also it tends to become not as practical because as a consumer of that document, I just read a lot of text and I don't know where it actually references the code. So what we encourage people to do is actually include references to the code. And by that, I mean snippets of the code itself, for example, also function names, variable names, anything that would actually help the reader have a walkthrough experience. So I would want to read a document and feel like Tim is standing by my side
然后他们也很难开始写，因为他们甚至不知道从哪里开始。而且它往往变得不那么实用，因为作为该文档的消费者，我只是读了很多文字，却不知道它实际上在哪里引用了代码。所以我们鼓励人们做的是实际上包含对代码的引用。我的意思是代码本身的片段，例如，还有函数名、变量名，任何实际上能帮助读者获得演练体验的东西。所以我想要阅读一份文档，感觉 Tim 就站在我身边
explaining to me what's happening here. And I did this because of that. And this line here does this. And then it calls this function within this repository and why I did it and so on. So for that, you might even want to start by looking at the code itself, identifying what parts of it you want to explain or what flow you're trying to convey.
向我解释这里发生了什么。我这样做是因为那个。这一行在这里做了这个。然后它调用了这个仓库中的这个函数，以及我为什么这样做等等。所以对于这一点，你甚至可能想从查看代码本身开始，确定你想要解释的部分，或者你试图传达的流程。
And then within that code, go select parts of the code itself and add comments to it, not within the code, but on an external document, including parts of that code. Yeah, that's a really good call out. I feel like when it comes to that side of it, people kind of fail in both ways. In one way, there's a documentation in the code, which is nice for that purpose. And then there's just, as you said, a wall of text, and it's very hard to map this wall of prose
然后在该代码中，去选择代码本身的部分并添加注释，不是在代码内，而是在外部文档中，包括该代码的部分。是的，那是一个非常好的呼吁。我觉得当涉及到这一面时，人们在两方面都失败了。一方面，代码中有文档，这对于那个目的来说很好。然后正如你所说，只是一堵文字墙，很难将这堵散文墙
back to the code base. And then on the other end of the spectrum, if someone gets their hands on Sphinx or one of these tools and they auto-generate 10,000 HTML files, but because they're auto-generated and 99.9% of the code isn't documented, you end up with just all this auto-generated text that is just agoraphobic. Like no one's going to read any of that. And it also kind of people don't. Right. And it's without context.
映射回代码库。然后在光谱的另一端，如果有人拿到了 Sphinx 或这些工具中的一个，他们自动生成了 10,000 个 HTML 文件，但因为它们是自动生成的，而且 99.9% 的代码没有被记录，你最终得到的所有这些自动生成的文本只是让人感到恐惧。就像没有人会读那些东西一样。而且它也让人……人们不会读。没错。而且它没有上下文。
Yeah. And people don't document it because it's now so big. And even if I documented it, who's going to know what's documented? And so that's two ways in which I've seen this fail. With the co-comments, you should absolutely be doing that. You should be doing that for the person that you you should absolutely be doing that. You should be doing that for the person that you're going to be in five minutes, and you should as well be doing that to anyone else that ever has to come across the code itself. But those comments are sort of
是的。而且人们不记录它，因为它现在太大了。即使我记录了它，谁会知道什么是被记录的？所以这是我见过它失败的两种方式。对于代码注释，你绝对应该这样做。你应该为那个……你绝对应该这样做。你应该为你五分钟后将要成为的那个人这样做，你也应该为任何必须接触代码本身的人这样做。但这些注释有点
like rungs on the ladder, and they need something to stand on. They need the higher level narrative to guide people through that. A good example is how do I make something configurable? Like I need to add a configuration value to the config file in this application. Where are the code paths I need to do that? All of the great code document, you know, if everything is document and comments there, that's awesome. But people tend to start their discovery on an endeavor. So having those things available, those common paths, or even uncommon paths, if they lead you through strange places, is thoroughly helpful for people to onboard with. And make sure that that has all these examples
像梯子上的横档，它们需要支撑的东西。它们需要更高层次的叙述来引导人们通过它。一个很好的例子是“我如何使某物可配置？”比如我需要在这个应用程序的配置文件中添加一个配置值。我需要执行哪些代码路径？所有伟大的代码文档，你知道，如果一切都在注释中记录了，那太棒了。但人们倾向于在一次尝试中开始他们的发现。所以拥有这些东西，那些常见的路径，甚至是罕见的路径，如果它们引导你穿过奇怪的地方，对人们入职来说是非常有帮助的。并确保它有所有这些示例
that you have in your code. If you need to show people how to, what dependencies do they need to inject when they ins instantiate the class? And then, oh, by the way, we use a lot of overloading here because Redis has so many verbs, we can't be bothered to implement them all since the requests are all handled the same. That would be a really good place to put that in there too. And that is the walkthrough that you need if you need to, maybe you want to cache a value in your web app instead of serving it all the time
你在你的代码中拥有的那些。如果你需要向人们展示如何做，他们在实例化类时需要注入什么依赖项？然后，哦，顺便说一下，我们在这里使用了很多重载，因为 Redis 有太多的动词，我们无法费心去实现它们全部，因为请求的处理方式都是一样的。那也是一个非常好的地方把它放进去。这就是你需要的那种演练，如果你需要的话，也许你想在你的 Web 应用程序中缓存一个值，而不是一直提供它
for performance reasons. That is a perfectly normal thing for someone to be assigned to do when they get to work in the morning. And if you don't have that there, half of their day is just going to be looking for what's relevant and they're not even going to get into the code yet. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So how do people go about doing that? I mean, we talked about kind of these two extremes, but if you wanted something with better balance, so if you want to be able to write a story, but have that story, you know, reference the code, like how do people go about building something like that? I mean, it's hard to kind of like deep link into a code base, right? Right. So basically what we first suggest people do is select parts of the code base and then reference them. There are a few ways to do that. The easiest way would be to copy paste snippets of the code to your document and just talk about that. The downside to that, and we can talk about this later, is that it may indeed become out of sync quite quickly.
出于性能原因。这对某人来说是一件非常正常的事情，当他们早上上班时被分配去做。如果你没有在那里记录，他们的一天有一半时间只是在寻找什么是相关的，他们甚至还没有进入代码。是的，这完全说得通。那么人们是如何做到这一点的呢？我的意思是，我们谈到了这两种极端，但如果你想要一些更好的平衡，所以如果你想能够写一个故事，但让那个故事引用代码，人们是如何构建像这样的东西的呢？我的意思是，很难深入链接到一个代码库，对吧？没错。所以基本上我们首先建议人们做的是选择代码库的部分，然后引用它们。有几种方法可以做到这一点。最简单的方法是复制粘贴代码片段到你的文档中，然后谈论它。这样做的缺点是，我们稍后可以谈论这个，它确实可能很快变得不同步。
But it does ease up the process of explaining a flow. You start by selecting the code you want to talk about, copy-pasting it to a document, and then from that document, you describe the flow itself. Also, by starting with the code, it makes it much easier for you as a writer to know everything you want to elaborate on what's important and what is not. Also, I think Tim mentioned before the inline comments in various use cases, and perhaps you have a specific function and you explain the logic of that function in one place, but those documents help you understand what this function does in the broader scope of a full flow. And it may be
但它确实简化了解释流程的过程。你从选择你想要谈论的代码开始，复制粘贴到文档中，然后从该文档中，你描述流程本身。此外，通过从代码开始，作为作者，你更容易知道你想要阐述的一切，什么是重要的，什么是不重要的。此外，我认为 Tim 之前提到了各种用例中的内联注释，也许你有一个特定的函数，你在一个地方解释了该函数的逻辑，但这些文档帮助你理解该函数在完整流程的更广泛范围内的作用。它可能
doing different things in different flows. I mean, the function itself will obviously have the same code, so it will technically do the same thing, but for different purposes. And that's the thing that's more insightful or more important for people to understand usually when they go through the entire flow of your program. One of the biggest telltale signs of not having great documentation is not seeing code reused when it should be. It means that people just aren't understanding that there was already something there that they could have used and adapted a little bit because it just wasn't explained to them. Oh, that is really interesting. Yeah, that's a really fascinating metric. Yeah, I mean,
在不同的流程中做不同的事情。我的意思是，函数本身显然会有相同的代码，所以它在技术上会做同样的事情，但用于不同的目的。而这通常是人们在浏览你的程序的整个流程时，更深刻或更重要的事情。没有优秀文档的最明显的迹象之一是，当代码应该被重用时却没有看到它被重用。这意味着人们只是不明白已经有了一些他们可以使用并稍微调整的东西，因为没有人向他们解释。哦，那真的很有趣。是的，这是一个非常迷人的指标。是的，我的意思是，
there's a whole tangent on what are good sort of metrics that you should capture when running a software team. But yeah, that is the one that I would want to add to the list. I love that idea. I mean, it's a little bit hard to measure, right? To measure when code could have been reused, but it's doable. It's a balance to it. Depends on your setting and what you're doing. In microservices, modern systems, we can just call them, some conventional wisdom goes out the window a little bit. One of the benefits of microservices is team A can use a different thread library than team B, right? So the whole dry thing doesn't always hold as much water as it used to. So it's not always like a
关于运行软件团队时应该捕获哪些好的指标，有一个完整的题外话。但是的，那是我想要添加到列表中的一个。我喜欢那个主意。我的意思是，这有点难衡量，对吧？衡量代码何时可以被重用，但这是可行的。它有一个平衡。取决于你的环境和你正在做的事情。在微服务、现代系统中，我们可以直接调用它们，一些传统智慧有点被抛弃了。微服务的好处之一是团队 A 可以使用与团队 B 不同的线程库，对吧？所以整个 DRY（不要重复自己）的东西并不总是像过去那样站得住脚。所以它并不总是像一个
telltale sign, but it can be if you take the context of everything else into place. It's one of the things that you should definitely watch out for. Cool. That makes sense. So let's dive into Swim here. So kind of give us a brief overview. We have a good idea of why you should write documentation, what are good practices, how you should write documentation, and what documentation is. How does Swim help with these things? So Swim encourages doing exactly what we just described, and that is creating code couple documentation. And by that, again, I mean documents that actually include references to the code itself. So when you create documentation with Swim, we help you include those code snippets or specific references to functions or to file path or other references from within
明显的迹象，但如果你把其他一切的背景考虑在内，它可能是。这是你绝对应该注意的事情之一。酷。这说得通。那么让我们深入了解 Swim。所以给我们一个简短的概述。我们对为什么要写文档、什么是好的做法、你应该如何写文档以及什么是文档有了一个很好的了解。Swim 是如何帮助解决这些事情的呢？所以 Swim 鼓励做我们刚才描述的事情，那就是创建代码耦合文档。我的意思是，实际上包含对代码本身引用的文档。所以当你用 Swim 创建文档时，我们帮助你包含那些代码片段或对函数、文件路径或来自内部的其他引用的特定引用
the code. But then one of the downsides of doing that without the appropriate tools would be that those references become quickly out of date. What we do at Swim is we track the changes to the code base as part of your CI or other hooks, like a Git hook. And then we help you by notifying you when the relevant code changed. And in case the change that had been made is not significant or doesn't really change the meaning of the document or the general flow you're trying to describe, we automatically suggest an update to the documentation. But if the change is really significant and drastic, for example, you documented an entire module and it doesn't exist anymore, then we tell you, okay, look,
代码。但如果没有适当的工具，这样做的缺点之一是这些引用会很快过时。我们在 Swim 所做的是，我们将代码库的更改跟踪为你的 CI 或其他钩子（如 Git 钩子）的一部分。然后，当相关代码发生变化时，我们会通过通知你来帮助你。如果所做的更改并不重要，或者并没有真正改变文档的含义或你试图描述的通用流程，我们会自动建议更新文档。但如果更改非常重大和剧烈，例如，你记录了一个完整的模块，而它不再存在了，那么我们会告诉你：“好吧，看，
this part here isn't up to date anymore. It's just incorrect. Please stop right now, not in a few months after the documentation is outdated, but while you're making the change and explain why you changed it and what's the current state and what's right about it. So basically we help you create documentation that we believe makes sense for developers to consume and also to keep it up to date. That makes sense. So stepping back a little bit. So, so most times if you're using something like GitHub, that's great. But even if you're at a private enterprise, you'll have some web view into your source control. There'll be some, hopefully some type of server you can visit
这部分不再是最新的了。它只是不正确的。请立即停止，不是在文档过时几个月后，而是在你进行更改时，并解释你为什么更改它，当前状态是什么，以及关于它什么是正确的。”所以基本上我们帮助你创建我们认为对开发者消费有意义的文档，并保持其最新。这说得通。所以退后一点。所以，大多数时候如果你使用像 GitHub 这样的东西，那很好。但即使你是在私有企业，你也会有一些对源代码控制的 Web 视图，希望会有某种你可以访问的服务器
on your intranet, and you can get a hyperlink to a file or even a specific range of lines in a file. And so you might say, well, if I'm going to build this documentation, I would add these links to line 90 to 100. I'm going to reference that block of code as I'm writing my documentation. This is the broader documentation. But then as you said, let's say someone adds a new function and they add it in line 80. Now your function got pushed down maybe 100 lines. And so if you don't update that link, it all of that, which is almost impossible if you're working with a large team, right? I mean, it's very hard for someone to know that you've put a hyperlink below them and any line they add will break that link. So Swim takes care of a lot of that. like an operational transform, in those cases, you can kind of alert people and say,
在你的内网，你可以获得一个指向文件甚至文件中特定行范围的超链接。所以你可能会说，如果我要构建这份文档，我会添加这些链接到第 90 到 100 行。我在写文档时会引用那个代码块。这是更广泛的文档。但正如你所说，假设有人添加了一个新函数，他们把它加在第 80 行。现在你的函数可能被推下了 100 行。所以如果你不更新那个链接，所有这些，如果你在一个大团队中工作，几乎是不可能的，对吧？我的意思是，有人很难知道你在他们下面放了一个超链接，他们添加的任何行都会破坏该链接。所以 Swim 处理了其中的大部分。就像一种操作转换，在这些情况下，你可以提醒人们并说：
yeah, this function reference is totally gone, or it's someone completely rewrote it, and now it's 100 lines. And so you should probably take a look at it again. Correct. So one part is the bookkeeping, as you named it. So that could be different line numbers, it could be a rename, or just moving the file somewhere else. Something that happens quite frequently is that people perform minor refactoring. So for example, you have a function that you try to describe in your document and it consists of 200 lines and someone just pushed, I don't know, renamed one variable or added one if to capture a specific edge case. The documentation still holds, but you still want to make sure
“是的，这个函数引用完全消失了，或者有人完全重写了它，现在它是 100 行。”所以你可能应该再看一眼。正确。所以一部分是簿记，正如你所命名的。所以那可能是不同的行号，可能是重命名，或者只是把文件移到别处。经常发生的事情是人们执行小的重构。例如，你有一个试图在文档中描述的函数，它由 200 行组成，而有人刚刚推送了，我不知道，重命名了一个变量或添加了一个 if 来捕获特定的边缘情况。文档仍然成立，但你仍然想确保
that it captures everything that is relevant. You don't want to show code that is not up to date because then developers will not believe that the documentation is up to date and captures what it should capture. So also in these cases, we suggest the changes that should be made. For example, now you need to include this edge case
它捕获了所有相关的内容。你不想展示不是最新的代码，因为那样开发者就不会相信文档是最新的并且捕获了它应该捕获的内容。所以同样在这些情况下，我们建议应该做出的更改。例如，现在你需要包含这个边缘情况
as well. But yeah, in cases where the code really changed drastically, it would just tell you, please pause now and reconsider your documentation and make it up to date again. Another approach, or sorry, another advantage of having code coupled documentation is that actually we know from within the code, what documentation covers it. So for example, while you're coding within your IDE, for example, we can show you, wait, this function here has a document describing it. And as opposed to inline comments, this document perhaps explains how this function takes a
也是如此。但是的，在代码确实发生剧烈变化的情况下，它只会告诉你：“请现在暂停并重新考虑你的文档，并使其再次保持最新。”另一种方法，或者抱歉，拥有代码耦合文档的另一个优势是，实际上我们从代码内部知道什么文档涵盖了它。例如，当你在 IDE 中编码时，例如，我们可以向你展示：“等等，这个函数有一个描述它的文档。”与内联注释相反，这份文档也许解释了该函数如何采取一个
role in a broader flow. Or maybe this function is actually described in multiple documents, each one describing a different flow. So you may want to be aware of that because, as you mentioned before, if the documentation exists and no one knows it exists when they need to, then it doesn't really help a lot. Yeah, that makes sense. I would actually love to ask you both of good examples of
在更广泛流程中的角色。或者也许这个函数实际上在多个文档中被描述，每个文档描述不同的流程。所以你可能想要意识到这一点，因为正如你之前提到的，如果文档存在，而当人们需要它时没有人知道它的存在，那么它并没有多大帮助。是的，这说得通。我实际上很想问你们两个关于
this on the web. But one example that I personally feel is really good is the PyTorch documentation. You know, they have the whole auto-generated thing going on and you can go, I think they call it the API section of their documentation. You can go there and you can actually browse the entire source tree with comments. And there's also auto-generated markdown HTML files for every file. But then they have these narratives like, here's how automatic differentiation works. Here's how sparse tensors work, right? In those narratives, they're linking back to either the API or the source code. I don't remember exactly how that works, but they have both and they're both really important. And actually, I love the idea you just mentioned. I mean, it would be great if while, you know, let's say you choose an autograd system, you choose Atom or AdaDelta or one of these
网络上的好例子。但我个人觉得真的很好的一个例子是 PyTorch 文档。你知道，他们有整个自动生成的东西，你可以去，我想他们称之为文档的 API 部分。你可以去那里，实际上浏览带有注释的整个源代码树。而且每个文件都有自动生成的 Markdown HTML 文件。但他们有这些叙述，比如“自动微分是如何工作的”、“稀疏张量是如何工作的”，对吧？在这些叙述中，他们链接回 API 或源代码。我不记得确切它是如何工作的，但他们两者都有，而且两者都非常重要。而且实际上，我喜欢你刚才提到的主意。我的意思是，如果当你，你知道，假设你选择了一个自动梯度系统，你选择 Atom 或 AdaDelta 或这些
things, and you're in Visual Studio Code and you type torch.optim.atom, right then and there, maybe they could pop up a little box. In addition to the box that tells you the arguments, which you might already know, I mean, there could be a little box saying, here's how automatic differentiation works and gives you kind of that more high-level information that's really important. I've seen that a lot of people pick on PHP, but the PHP community is really, really, really good because of some of the quirks within the language itself. If you go to a lot of the PHP frameworks out there, you can find really, really good documentation. That's one of the ways that these open-source frameworks compete. How well documented they are is a big determination of which one your team is likely to use.
东西之一，并且你在 Visual Studio Code 中输入 `torch.optim.atom`，就在那时，也许他们可以弹出一个小框。除了告诉你参数的框（你可能已经知道了），我的意思是，可以有一个小框说：“这是自动微分的工作原理”，并给你那种非常重要的更高级别的信息。我看到很多人挑剔 PHP，但 PHP 社区真的、真的、真的很好，因为语言本身的一些怪癖。如果你去看看那里许多 PHP 框架，你可以找到非常、非常好的文档。这就是这些开源框架竞争的方式之一。文档记录得有多好是你的团队可能使用哪一个的重要决定因素。
And PHP CodeIgniter, as well as Laravel and Symfony, can do deep dives into and say, look, this is to overcome a language feature or something that isn't implemented in the language yet. Or this is because of a way that the language works, that we're implementing it this way. And those things have been called out, first and foremost, right where you would need to have it before you start scratching your head, wondering what you were doing wrong. So those are really good examples of documentation.
而 PHP CodeIgniter，以及 Laravel 和 Symfony，可以深入研究并说：“看，这是为了克服语言特性或语言中尚未实现的东西。或者这是因为语言工作的方式，我们以这种方式实现它。”而这些事情已经被提出来了，首先，就在你需要它的地方，在你开始挠头、想知道你做错了什么之前。所以这些是文档的很好的例子。
And we, in the microservices world, we're kind of missing that. We don't have that anymore because frameworks are being thrown out there and we're writing lighter code that goes a lot faster. But at the same time, we are giving up a lot of documentation that was already written for us about the stack that we're using. And I don't think that the true cost of that is conceptualized by CTOs and CIOs more than it should be. Yeah, that makes sense. I think maybe post-hoc, they're looking and saying, why did our productivity go down the drain?
而我们，在微服务世界中，我们有点缺失了这一点。我们不再有那个了，因为框架被抛出来了，我们正在编写运行速度快得多的更轻的代码。但与此同时，我们放弃了许多关于我们正在使用的堆栈的已经为我们写好的文档。而且我不认为 CTO 和 CIO 对此的真实成本有比应该有的更多的概念化。是的，这说得通。我想也许事后，他们看着并说：“为什么我们的生产力下降了？”
What they should be doing is being defensive and kind of looking ahead and saying, having the right metrics as we talked about, saying, okay, well, why is the health of our documentation going down? And that would allow you to be proactive. My favorite features of Swim is the CLI tools that we have for it, which will actually tell you if your coverage on a given repository has gone down. If you basically set a mark there to what you want to be as far as a score between zero out of a hundred, how well documented are you? You can check that easily. And it's also really great that you can do that at the pre-commit phase, which I think is good. Number one, because I just ran Twitter poll not that long ago about how long
他们应该做的是采取防御措施，向前看，并说，拥有我们谈到的正确指标，说：“好吧，为什么我们文档的健康状况在下降？”这将允许你主动出击。我最喜欢的 Swim 功能是我们拥有的 CLI 工具，它实际上会告诉你你在给定仓库上的覆盖率是否下降了。如果你基本上在那里设定了一个标记，即你想要的分数，作为 0 到 100 之间的分数，你记录得有多好？你可以轻松检查。而且你可以在预提交阶段这样做，这我认为很好。第一，因为我不久前刚在 Twitter 上做了一个民意调查，关于如果你进行完整构建，CI 实际运行需要多长时间。答案是 5 分钟到几小时不等。所以我认为有些团队可能并不那么渴望在 PR 流程之前更新它。当 lint 运行并且空格被转换为制表符时，正如它应该的那样。不过，我不想在这个播客上引发那场战争。我们实际上有一个，不是整集，但我们有一个编辑器剧集，我想，我不确定 Patrick 和我是否同意，但无论如何，关于它有激烈的讨论。软件开发中那些永远会存在的、高度争议的领域之一。那就像编程的“自行车棚”。
it takes for CIs to actually run if you're doing a full build. And the answer to that was anywhere between five minutes and hours for that to run. So I think some teams might not be all that eager to update it before you even do the PR at that process. When the lints run and spaces get converted into tabs, as it should be. I don't want to start that war on this podcast, though. We actually had a, not a whole episode, but we had an editor episode where we, I think, I'm not sure if Patrick and I agreed or not, but either way, it was like heated discussion about it. One of the tightly contentious areas of software development that will always be, it will always be there. That is like the bike shed of programming.
如果你进行完整构建，CI 实际运行需要的时间。答案是五分钟到几小时不等。所以我认为有些团队可能并不那么热衷于在提交 PR 之前就进行更新。当代码检查运行，空格被转换为制表符时，本该如此。不过我不想在这个播客里挑起那场战争。我们确实有过一期，虽然不是整集，但我们有一期关于编辑器的节目，我想，我不确定我和 Patrick 是否达成了一致，但无论如何，那是一场激烈的讨论。这是软件开发中一直存在且永远会存在的争议领域之一。这就像编程界的“自行车棚”问题。
But anyway, one of the things that I like about just the design of Swim is it's all of the little tools that you need to couple all this stuff together in the ways that we're talking about. You could do it other ways. I mean, there's other ways that you could do it. You could look at file times on when documentation was last edited. That's a great way to pick up stuff that's probably starting to stink a little bit. You can trigger documentation builds based on major new versions and stuff like that. Swim just does it in a way that doesn't present you with the least resistance to actually keeping it up to date. I think, Jason, beforehand, you mentioned that when something goes wrong nowadays, we add a test to cover this case.
但无论如何，我喜欢 Swim 设计的一点是，它提供了将我们所讨论的这些内容整合在一起所需的所有小工具。你当然可以用其他方式来做。我的意思是，还有其他方法。你可以查看文档最后一次编辑的文件时间。这是一种发现那些可能开始变得“过时”的内容的好方法。你可以根据重大版本更新等情况触发文档构建。Swim 只是以一种不会让你感到阻力的方式，让你真正保持文档的更新。我想，Jason，你之前提到过，现在如果出了问题，我们会添加一个测试来覆盖这种情况。
And I think that happens partially because the world of testing and continuous integration has evolved so much in recent years. And we're trying to get the same documentation. So we want to help you create documentation while you write your code and also make sure continuously that it's still up to date and that it covers everything you want it to cover. I think that is very similar to tests in that manner. Yeah, it totally makes sense. I think having the right metrics and getting that instantaneous feedback is so important for building the right incentives. And I think for tests, as you said, tests have, I wouldn't say
我认为这部分是因为测试和持续集成领域近年来发展迅速。我们正试图在文档方面实现同样的目标。所以我们希望在你编写代码的同时帮助你创建文档，并持续确保它保持最新，且涵盖了你想要涵盖的所有内容。我认为这在某种程度上与测试非常相似。是的，这完全说得通。我认为拥有正确的指标并获得即时反馈对于建立正确的激励机制非常重要。对于测试，正如你所说，测试已经，我不会说
they've been around longer, but people have spent maybe more time and energy on figuring out how to write software tests and software documentation. And so they've set up those right incentives. And most of the things I work on have been open sourced. And we'll have people who will just increase our test coverage. And it could be, maybe they're in the middle of learning how our repository works. And it's just, you get this instant gratification for doing that. You feel like you've really contributed because you just see that result. And so getting documentation into that flywheel
它们存在的时间更长，但人们可能在弄清楚如何编写软件测试和软件文档上花费了更多的时间和精力。所以他们建立了正确的激励机制。我参与的大多数项目都是开源的。我们会有人主动增加我们的测试覆盖率。这可能是因为他们正在学习我们的代码库是如何工作的。你因为这样做而获得了即时的满足感。你会觉得你真的做出了贡献，因为你看到了结果。所以将文档纳入这种飞轮效应中
is super powerful. Right. I think it's also a means of gamification in some means. And you get like this goal you strive for. But also it helps you visually see what parts of your code base are currently visible to people who are new to it. So for example, if you're able to see that this module
是非常强大的。没错。我认为这在某种程度上也是一种游戏化。你得到了一个努力的目标。但它也帮助你直观地看到你的代码库中哪些部分对于新手来说是可见的。例如，如果你能看到这个模块
or this folder or this file has corresponding documentation and this file doesn't, that you know that for the first file, you don't need to worry as much. And actually we've also seen it with teams where knowledge is very much concentrated. So let's say you have one person who has been responsible for a module for
或者这个文件夹或这个文件有相应的文档，而那个文件没有，你就知道对于第一个文件，你不需要那么担心。实际上，我们也看到过团队中知识高度集中的情况。假设有一个人负责一个模块已经
a year now, and only that person knows what's been going on in this folder. And if that person just leaves the company tomorrow, what would happen to all the files there, to all the knowledge? And again, it's not just the code that lives there now, all the decisions that that person has made in the process of creating this code, maybe the path he hasn't taken and the things he hasn't implemented because he thought about them, but he had really good reasons not to implement. So all of that knowledge is going to be gone. And if you have tools that show you that currently all the knowledge of the team is concentrated on one person for a specific
一年了，只有那个人知道这个文件夹里发生了什么。如果那个人明天离开公司，那里的所有文件、所有的知识会发生什么？再说一次，现在那里不仅有代码，还有那个人在创建代码过程中所做的所有决定，也许是他没有采取的路径，以及他没有实现的功能，因为他考虑过，但他有充分的理由不去实现。所以所有这些知识都将消失。如果你有工具能向你展示目前团队的所有知识都集中在某个人身上，针对特定的
folder or module or repository, then it also gives you an incentive to know that you need to invest now in creating documentation for that specific part. Yeah, that's a good call. That seems like a nightmare scenario, right? Where one person kind of owns a whole directory or something and no one else really has any. They all have to kind of trust that person. And that person goes on PTO, everyone just has to wait until they come back to edit stuff in that folder. What is actually a bit of a sidetrack here, do you have any horror stories, documentation or just code health horror stories that you'd
文件夹、模块或存储库，那么它也会激励你意识到现在需要投资为该特定部分创建文档。是的，说得好。这听起来像是一场噩梦，对吧？一个人拥有整个目录或类似的东西，而其他人真的什么都不知道。他们都必须信任那个人。那个人去休假了，其他人就只能等他回来才能编辑那个文件夹里的东西。这其实有点跑题了，你有什么恐怖故事，关于文档或代码健康的恐怖故事吗？
want to share that the audience would get a kick out of. I have an interesting story about some jellyfish. Sure, let's hear it. So I was working in embedded systems. It's one of my hobbies. And occasionally I do some consulting to help people do it. So is this like Arduino type stuff? Arduino, gumsticks, Raspberry Pis. And then there's also some industrial single board computers out there, different varying architectures.
你想分享一下，让听众觉得有趣的吗？我有一个关于水母的有趣故事。当然，说来听听。我当时在做嵌入式系统。这是我的爱好之一。偶尔我会做一些咨询工作来帮助人们。这是像 Arduino 那样的东西吗？Arduino、Gumstix、Raspberry Pi。还有一些工业单板计算机，架构各不相同。
Cool, cool. Very nice. Getting operating systems into small places and you've got that four megabyte ceiling is really, it reminds me of poking away on my old 386. So it's a lot of fun to do sometimes. Yeah, yeah. And there was a power company in Asia that had a problem with jellyfish. And the problem was the freshwater intake for the
酷，酷。非常好。将操作系统放入狭小的空间，而且你有 4MB 的上限，这让我想起在旧的 386 上折腾的日子。所以有时候做起来很有趣。是的，是的。亚洲有一家电力公司遇到了水母的问题。问题是冷却发电厂涡轮机的淡水进水口，如果叶轮在错误的时间启动，取决于海平面的位置，它们就会被堵塞。这真的会把机器堵死，情况很糟糕。所以他们开始部署这些鱼类探测传感器来应对这种情况，这样如果有一大群鱼经过，工厂在那时就不会吸入那么多水，也就不会对环境造成那么大的破坏。像这样的系统，你编写它，你认为，好吧，这只是一个临时的东西，你知道，因为洋流总是在变化之类的，结果却并非如此。结果发现，支柱是建立在一些
turbines that cooled the power plant, the impellers would get clogged if they came on at the wrong time, depending on where the sea levels were. And it would literally gum up the works and it was bad. So they started deploying these fish finding sensors in order to combat that so that if there were like a whole school of fish going by, the plant could not take in as much water right then and then it wouldn't be so disruptive to the environment. Systems like that, that you write, you know, and you think, okay, this is going to be like a, a temporary thing, you know, because the ocean currents are always changing and stuff like that turns out not to be. And then it turns out that, you know, pillars are built on top of something
非常、非常不稳固的东西之上的，那是你很久以前作为一个快速变通方案实现的。这种情况在软件中经常发生。但特别是在你的代码运行在水下，你无法真正管理它的时候。拥有记录在案的重启这些系统的方法，甚至让人们知道这些系统的存在，是绝对至关重要的。所以我帮忙编写了鱼类探测器的程序，它们通过单线总线与接收器通信，工作得很好。
really, really rickety that you implemented a long time ago as a quick workaround. And that tends to happen all the time in software. But in particular, where your code is like running submerged undersea, where you can't really manage it. It is absolutely critical that you have documented ways to restart these systems and even let people know that these systems existed. And so I helped with getting the fish finders programmed and they were communicating over a one wire bus back to a receiver and they were working well.
在我最后一次查看该代码 10 年后，我接到了一个疯狂的电话，询问有关它的问题。显然没有人知道那些东西被部署了。没有人知道它们在做什么。他们唯一能找到的就是一个我几乎不再使用的电话号码。所以幸运的是，他们能够联系到我，找出为什么海水没有被吸入
And I got a, I got a frantic phone call 10 years after I had last looked at that code with questions about it. And apparently no one knows that those things were deployed. No one knew what they were doing. And the only thing they could find was a phone number that I was almost not in possession of anymore. So luckily they were able to reach me to find out why seawater wasn't getting pulled in
控制回路的那一部分。但这只是其中一件有趣的事情，如果你对此不是非常、非常、非常谨慎，并且没有在当时就做好，那么很有可能有人会后悔。而且那个人可能是你，也可能不是。是的，这确实是一个很好的提醒。Patrick 和我在另一家公司工作，他们称之为高级研究实验室。那就是我们多年前最初相遇的地方，我想，大概 13 年前还是什么的。当时，神经网络是过街老鼠。
in that part of the control loop. But that was just one of the interesting things where you can, if you're not very, very, very deliberate about it and you don't do it right then, there's a very, very, very good chance that someone is going to regret that. And it may or may not be you. Yeah, that's a really good call out. Patrick and I worked, they called it the advanced research lab at another company. And that's how we originally met many years ago, I think what, I don't know, 13 years ago or something now. So at the time, neural networks were a pariah.
就像如果你相信神经网络，几乎不可能毕业。你知道，Marvin Minsky，所有这些人都被彻底否定了。没有人认为神经网络或深度学习会有什么成就。而我们就在这个实验室里试图让它运行起来。现在快进，你知道，我回到了东海岸，我正在和一些朋友，一些前同事交谈，他们说，他们还在使用我们当时写的代码，那时我们以为没人会读它或用它做任何事。我甚至不知道我们是否使用了版本控制，因为我们只是觉得，好吧，你知道，这只是一个没人相信的抛弃型想法。
Like if you believed in neural networks, it was almost impossible to graduate. You know, Marvin Minsky, all these people have been totally discredited. And nobody thought neural networks or deep learning was ever going to amount to anything. And here we are in this lab trying to get this up and running. And now fast forward, you know, I was talking to, you know, I went back to the East Coast was ever going to amount to anything. And here we are in this lab trying to get this up and running. And now fast forward, I was talking to, I went back to the East Coast and I was talking to some friends of mine, some former colleagues, and they said, they're still using some of the code we wrote back when we thought no one was ever going to read this or do anything with it. And I don't even know if we use source control because we just felt like, well, you know, here's this throwaway idea that no one believes in.
所以你永远、永远不知道。拥有某种方式来延续这一点非常重要，因为它最终可能会拯救水母生态系统，或者最终写出很多很多人在很久之后使用的东西。我和一些实现过 Palm Pilot 的人谈过，如果你还记得那些的话，Palm V 配备那个 LCD 和手写笔。直到今天，还有人在使用他为 Palm V 到 Linux 的热同步编写的代码，而 Palm 可能已经 20 年没有支持它了。所以，是的，看到什么东西留存下来，并在你完成它很久之后继续为人们提供价值，真是太神奇了。这就是我们进入这个领域的原因之一，也是开源如此有趣的原因之一，因为你，我的意思是，你永远不知道你什么时候会最终成为，你知道，你写的代码，当你是一个非常
And so you just never, ever know. And it's so important to have some type of way to kind of continue that because it could end up being, you could end up saving the jellyfish ecosystem or end up writing something a lot of people use a long time later. I've talked to people that implemented things that like the Palm Pilot, if you remember those, the Palm V with that LCD and the stylus. And there are people to this day that are using code that he wrote for Palm V hot sync to Linux, which has not been supported by Palm for probably 20 years now. So yeah, it's just amazing what stays out there and what continues to provide value to people long after you do it. And that's one of the reasons why we get into this. And one of the reasons why open source is so much fun because you, I mean, you never know when you're going to end up being, you know, code that you wrote when you were a very
不同的人时，最终会节省某人大量的时间。这太棒了。我记得有一次在军队的时候，一个朋友打电话让我帮他调试这个操作系统，消息就是传不过去。所以我们知道它们是从一端发送的，我们需要在另一端接收它们。具体来说，那些是被优先处理为最重要和最紧急的消息，但我们无法接收到。而负责那个系统的负责人几个月前离开了。所以我们不得不尝试自己弄清楚
different person ends up, you know, saving someone a lot of time. It's great. I remember one time back in the army days where a friend called me to help him debug this operational system where messages just didn't come through. So we knew they were being sent from one end and we needed to receive them at the other end. And specifically, those were messages who were prioritized as the most important and urgent to be sent and we couldn't receive them. And the person who had been responsible for that system left a few months before. So we had to just try and figure out
一切。这花了一些时间，但最终，我们发现系统的一端，换句话说，一个开发人员认为 1 代表最紧急，10 代表最不紧急。而负责另一端的开发人员认为情况恰恰相反。哦，不。是的，那里没有任何文档帮助我们。而且，是的，它确实导致了很多重要的消息在途中丢失。是的，那绝对是一场文档噩梦。那么回到 Swim，
everything on our own. And it took some time, but in the end, we found out that one end of the system, or in other words, one developer assumed that one meant the most urgent and 10 meant the least urgent. And the other developer responsible for the other end assumed it was just the opposite case. Oh, no. Yeah, there was no documentation helping us there. And yeah, it actually got a lot of important messages to get lost in the way. Yeah, that is definitely a documentation nightmare. So going to Swim,
所以想象一下光谱的两端。一端是刚刚起步的人，你知道，他们还在上高中或大学，他们正在寻找理想中免费的东西，如果不是免费的，至少是非常、非常划算的，并且是为他们在 GitHub 上拥有的个人项目准备的，可能是在一个公共存储库中。然后在光谱的另一端，是那些在行业里的人，你知道，他们，你知道，他们
so imagine there's sort of two ends of the spectrum. On one end, there is somebody who is just starting out, you know, they're in high school or college, and they're looking for something that is ideally free, or if not free, just very, very cost efficient, and something for a personal project that they have on GitHub, probably on a public repository. And then on the other end of the spectrum, there are the folks who are in an industry, you know, and they, you know, they
拥有他们非常保护的知识产权的源代码控制，并且他们有一个内部的，也许他们有一个内部部署的 GitLab 之类的东西。那么 Swim 能为这两种受众提供什么呢？Swim 一直并将继续为开源项目免费提供。所以每当有人有个人项目或只是一个开源项目时，他们都可以免费使用 Swim。对于企业，我们有多种解决方案。其中一些意味着我们根本无法访问代码库。所以那些认为不提供访问权限非常重要的客户可以感到安全和放心。酷。
have source control that is their intellectual property that they're very protective over, and they have an internal, maybe they have an internal deployment of GitLab or something like that. And so what can Swim offer these two kind of audiences? So Swim has been and will be free for open source projects. So whenever anyone has a personal project or just an open source project, they can use Swim for free. And for enterprises, we have multiple solutions. Some of them mean that we don't actually get access to the code base at all. So clients who find it really important not to give access can be safe and sure. Cool.
那么它是如何... 第一个太棒了。所以人们一定要去看看。我们会在节目说明中提供链接等等。所以如果你在外面，你是一个业余爱好者，去看看这个。你会感到惊讶的，特别是如果你是一名博士生，或者如果你正在做你的毕业设计项目，如果它是有潜力的，对吧？你知道，我的博士项目在 GitHub 上仍然获得了很多星标，而那段代码绝对是糟糕透顶的。所以，你知道，你想构建一些非常好的东西。此外，它会让你的简历看起来不错。所以，所以一定要去看看免费版本。
So how does that... The first one is amazing. So people definitely check it out. We'll have links in the show notes and all of that. So if you are out there and you're a hobbyist, check this out. You would be amazed, especially if you're a PhD student or if you're doing your senior design project, if it's something that has legs, right? You know, my PhD project still gets a lot of stars on GitHub and that code is absolutely atrocious. So, you know, you want to build something really nice. Also, it's going to make your resume look good. And so, and so definitely check out the free version.
那是一个不用动脑筋的选择。跳进企业领域，它是如何工作的？如果有人想使用 Swim，但你知道，他们有非常严格的知识产权规则，或者，你知道，他们不想经历，或者，你知道，他们不想跳过一堆障碍来获得批准。他们会怎么做？是他们自己在自己的集群上部署它，还是它是如何工作的？它是一个用 Electron 编写的应用程序。所以它具有高度的可移植性。Swim 使用 Git 作为存储的后端。
That's a, that's a no brainer. Jumping into the, into the enterprise, how does that work? Like if someone wants to use Swim, but you know, they, they have very strict kind of IP rules or, or, you know, they're, they don't want to go through, but jump through a bunch of hoops to get approval. How would they go about doing that? Is it something where they deploy it on their own cluster or how does that work? It's an app that's written in Electron. So it's highly portable. And the Swim works with Git as the backend for the storage.
它会在存储库中创建一个 .swm 目录，类似于 .git 目录。这就是所有内容暂存的地方。在我们这边，我们并没有真正获得关于你的代码或类似内容的任何信息。我们得到的只是关系映射，这样我们就知道这个文档播放列表是与这个存储库绑定的。但我们这边全是哈希值，
And it will create a.directory,.swm inside the repo, similar to the.git directory. And that's where everything is staged. On our side, we don't really get anything about your code or anything like that. All we get is some relational mappings so that we know that this playlist of documentation is tied to this repository. But it's all hashes on our side,
所以他们不必担心这一点。而且它目前还处于非常测试阶段，但为了消费开发人员文档，这样你就不必绝对拥有存储库的访问权限才能阅读它。这是我们非常努力支持的一个大用例。哦，这说得通。好的。所以基本上，我想你提到了这一点，但我直到现在才把它们联系在一起。所以因为文档，或者说，Swim 的工件在存储库中，那么你也不需要某种存储大量信息的集中式服务。
so they don't have to worry about that. And it's currently very beta right now, but for consuming developer documentation so that you don't absolutely have to have access to the repo in order to read it too. That's a big use case that we're trying very hard to support. Oh, that makes sense. Okay. So basically, and I think you touched on this, but I didn't put it all together until now. So because the documentation or let's say, like the things, the artifacts for Swim are in the repository, then you don't also need some centralized service that's storing a bunch of information.
所以每个人都运行 Swim 桌面应用程序，它实际上是通过 Git 存储库的提交进行通信的。我理解对了吗？在某种程度上，是的。Swim 会理解团队的概念，以及哪些存储库与哪些团队绑定。所以 Swim 会知道你是否在本地机器上安装了所有存储库，因为它能够找到它们。
So each person runs the Swim desktop app and effectively it's communicating through the commits to the Git repository. Did I get that right? To a certain extent, yes. What Swim will do is it'll understand a concept of teams and which repositories are tied to which teams. So Swim will know if you have all of the repositories installed on your local machine because it will be able to find them.
或者它会告诉你，嘿，你需要从中央存储库拉取以获取最新的文档。或者，嘿，你缺少一个存储库。如果你想安装它，这是你需要运行的克隆存储库的命令，这样你就可以得到它。Swim 也依赖 Git 进行推送。所以存在一定程度的中心化，因为它存在于 Git 中。所以很明显，如果你编写文档，它存储在你的存储库中，并且你希望你的团队能够消费它，你需要能够把它放在一个他们可以拉取的地方。同样，如果你在一个分支上编写文档，并且你希望人们能够消费它，他们要么必须检出你的分支，要么你必须将其合并到主分支。
Or it will tell you, hey, you need to pull from the central repo in order to get the up-to-date docs. Or, hey, you're missing a repository. If you want to install it, here's the command that you need to run to clone the repo for your site so that you can get it. And Swim also relies on Git for pushing. So there's centralization to the point that it exists in Git. So obviously, if you write documentation, it's stored in your repo and you want your team to be able to consume it, you need to be able to put it in a place where they can pull it. Likewise, if you're working on documentation in a branch and you want people to be able to assume it, they'll either have to check out your branch or you'll have to merge that with the master branch.
没错。所以它基本上意味着，如果某人有存储库的访问权限，那么他们也就有文档的访问权限。但如果他们没有存储库的访问权限，他们就没有文档的访问权限。这不是 Swim 处理的事情，而是你自己处理的事情，例如，通过使用 GitHub。是的，完全说得通。所以，好的，这说得通。如果有人在为企业公司工作，他们想尝试 Swim，他们会怎么做？是他们自己，你知道，有试用版，还是他们可能刷信用卡，然后自己尝试一下？还是说，你必须去找你的软件工程总监，游说开始使用它？
Right. So what it basically means is that if someone has access to the repository, then they also have access to the documentation. But if they don't have access to the repo, they don't have access to the documentation. And it's not something that Swaim handles, but something that you handle on your own, for example, by using GitHub. Yeah, totally makes sense. And so, okay, that makes sense. So if someone is working for enterprise company, they want to try out Swim, how would they go about doing that? Is it something where they, on their own, you know, is there a trial or they maybe swipe their credit card and they try it out on their own? Or is it something where you kind of, you have to go to your software engineering director and kind of lobby to start using it?
目前我们处于测试阶段。所以你在网站上联系我们，但你总是欢迎自己开始免费工作，团队也可以。它是免费的。所以你能够体验产品，创建文档，与人分享，看到它随着代码的发展保持最新，并在刷信用卡或类似的事情之前从使用 Swim 中获得一些价值。所以开始是免费的，我们也非常渴望帮助你入门，看看人们如何使用 Swim，以及他们创建了什么样的优秀文档，然后使用 Swim 进行消费。
So currently we are in beta. So you reach out to us on the website, but you're always welcome to start working on your own for free and also for a team. It's going to be for free. So you're able to experience with the product, create documentation, share it with people, see that it remains up to date as the code evolves and to get some value of using Swim before swiping a credit card or something like that. So the beginning is for free and we are also very eager to help you getting started and seeing how people use Swim and what kind of great documentation they create and then consume using Swim.
酷。这说得通。所以是的，我认为这太棒了。每个人都绝对应该去看看。我们会在节目说明中提供链接等等。对于不知道的人，节目说明通常链接自，取决于你的播客播放器，几乎总是有某种详细信息部分。我们总是把节目说明的链接放在那里。酷。那么让我们稍微谈谈 Swim 作为一家公司。Swim 成立多久了，它是如何设置的？它是一家分布式公司吗？整个故事是什么样的？
Cool. That makes sense. So yeah, I think this is amazing. Everyone should definitely check this out. We'll have links to the show in the show notes and all of that. And the show notes, for people who don't know, are linked from usually, depending on your podcast player, there's almost always some kind of details section. And we always put a link to the show notes there. Cool. So let's jump into Swim a little bit as a company. So how old is Swim and how is Swim sort of set up? Is it a distributed company? What's sort of that whole story like?
Swim 成立于 2019 年 9 月。所以是一年半前。我们开始并总部设在以色列。实际上，我们的第一批员工是在 COVID-19 期间使用 Swim 入职的。当时，那是以色列的第一次封锁。每个人都吓坏了。所以人们是远程入职的，这在当时看起来似乎不像今天那么普遍。所以我们实际上很幸运，拥有了 Swim 的第一个版本
So Swim was founded in September 2019. So one and a half years ago. And we started and based in Israel. And actually our first hires were onboarded using Swim and during COVID-19. And at that time, it was the first lockdown here in Israel. Everyone was freaking out. So people were being onboarded remotely, which back then seemed a bit not as common as today, I would say. So we were actually pretty lucky to have the very first version of Swim
用于我们前几名员工的入职。所以我们是半远程开始的。所以大多数第一批员工是在以色列开始的，但我们很早就开始从美国增加人员，当然还有 Tim。而且我们那里还有其他几名成员。而且我们现在还有一名开发人员从德国加入我们。所以此时此刻，团队是半分布式的。酷。那么 Swim 的工程师典型的一天是什么样的？你们用什么交流？你认为有什么有趣的事情，让你们公司
to use for onboarding our few first hires. So we started semi-remotely. So most of the first hires started in Israel, but we started adding people from the US quite early on, Tim, of course. And also we have a few other members there. And also we have one developer joining us from Germany now. So the team is semi-distributed, I would say, at this point. Cool. And so what is a typical day like for an engineer at Swim? What do you use to communicate? And what is something that you think would be kind of interesting and makes your company
从日常角度来看脱颖而出？所以我认为我们每天做的第一件事，我们有一个每日会议，这很常见。在开始时，我们有一个部分，我们称之为“搁浅在海上”。我们在 Swim 使用了很多游泳术语。哦，这说得通。是的。所以我们有一个“搁浅在海上”部分，欢迎每个人提出他们
kind of stand out from a kind of day-to-day perspective? So I think one of the first things we do every day, so we have a daily session, which is very common. And in the beginning, we have a section we call the Stranded at Sea. We use a lot of swimming lingo at Swim. Oh, that makes sense. Yeah. So we have a Stranded at Sea section where everyone is welcome to raise any issue they
可能遇到的任何问题。而且我认为因为我们是一家为开发人员创建工具的公司，所以我们的开发人员也在日常生活中使用该产品。所以他们都有自己的观点，并且对我们应该如何创建这个产品有很多想法和新点子。所以几乎每次每日会议都包含一些关于产品本身的见解，以及我们如何随着时间的推移演进、实现和改进它。我们还有，而且我认为在 Swim 中非常酷，从一开始，我们就有一个仪式，我们称之为“Swiminar”。
may have. And I think because we are a company who creates tools for developers, then our developers are also using the product on a day-to-day basis. So they are all opinionated and have a lot of thoughts and new ideas as to how we should create this product as well. So almost every daily session includes some insights about the product itself and how we may evolve, implement, and improve it over time, actually. What we also have, and I think is quite cool in Swim, straight from the beginning, we have a ritual we call Swiminars.
所以它就像一个研讨会，但是一个 Swiminar。我们每隔一周做一次。然后公司的一个人可以花两天时间学习新东西。这可以是深入的技术研究，比如 Git 的内部结构或文件系统，或者 Electron 中的某些东西，或者与 Swim 相关或不完全相关的任何东西。或者它可以是其他东西，比如产品问题或任何你感兴趣的，你发现其他人也会感兴趣的东西。然后那个人可以与整个团队分享。
So it's like a seminar, but a Swiminar. We do that every other week. And then one person from the company can take two days to learn something new. It could be a deep dive tech research into something like the internals of Git or a file system or something in Electron or anything related or not exactly related to swim. Or it could be something else like product issues or anything you're interested with that you find other people will find interesting. And then that person gets to share it with the entire team.
我们通常花一个半小时进行那次演讲，然后讨论所展示的内容。我也认为在 Swim 很酷的是，正如我所说，我们一直使用我们自己的产品，所以我们一直创建文档、消费它并更新它。然后每当我们去和其他公司谈论它时，我们总是可以使用我们自己的例子。
We usually spend one and a half hours having that talk and then discussing whatever was presented. What I also think is cool at Swim is that, as I said, we use our own product all the time, so we get to create documentation, consume it, and update it all the time. And then whenever we go and talk with other companies about it, we can always use our own examples.
正如我们之前提到的，我们并不真正知道 Swim 的客户或用户那里发生了什么，如果他们不是开源项目，因为我们无法访问他们的代码，但我们总是有我们内部如何使用它的例子。酷。是的，这说得通。你们如何处理时区差异？所以我相信，我想，我的家人在意大利和以色列，如果我错了请纠正我，我对地理一窍不通，但以色列是，是的，以色列绝对在意大利的东边，意大利是八小时。所以，所以我不知道 Tim 在美国的哪里，但我的意思是，你可能面临
As we have mentioned beforehand, we don't really know what's going on at clients or users of Swim who are not open source projects because we don't have access to their code, but we always have examples of how we use it internally. Cool. Yeah, that makes sense. How do you navigate the time zone difference? So I believe, I want to, so my family's in Italy and Israel, correct me if I'm wrong, I'm terrible at geography, but Israel is, yeah, Israel is definitely east of Italy and Italy is eight hours. So, so I don't know where Tim is in the U S but I mean, you're looking at potentially
像 10 小时的时区差距。对吧。那么你们，你们如何处理这个问题？七小时。是的，它，它并不糟糕。我实际上是一个糟糕的例子，因为我已经在，我想，大概 18 年没有在实体办公室工作过了。哦，哇。我一直在远程工作。
like a 10 hour time zone gap. Right. And so how do you, how do you handle that? Seven hours. It's yeah, it's, it's not terrible. I'm actually a terrible example at this because I have not worked in a physical office in, I think, like 18 years. Oh, wow. I've been remoting.
我的意思是，远程工作只是我做的事情。Stack Overflow 是一家远程优先的公司，现在仍然是。当我还在那里工作时，我比每个人都早 13 个小时。我当时住在马尼拉大都会。哦，有趣。你必须对此非常谨慎，你必须确保你确保你在正确的信息反弹给你的地方，无论你什么时候得到它。但协调并没有，它并没有破坏它。这很容易做到。偶尔我可能不得不早起一个小时参加更早的会议，但就覆盖范围而言
I mean, remoting is just something that I do. Stack Overflow was a remote-first company, still is. And when I was working there, I was 13 hours ahead of everybody. I was living in Metro Manila at the time. Oh, interesting. You have to be very deliberate about it and you have to make sure that you make sure you're in the places where the right information bounces off of you, no matter kind of what time you get to it. But the coordination doesn't, it doesn't break it. It's easy to do. Occasionally I might have to get up at like an hour earlier to make an earlier meeting, but the coverage as far as
客户而言，几乎是全天候的，这太棒了。它实际上是全天候的，这对他们来说太棒了。所以这并不太糟糕。如果我在西海岸，情况可能会有点不同。可能没有那么多的重叠。但有了 Slack 和我们拥有的互联网应用程序，以及我们可用于交流的其他一切。而且知识共享从一开始就是公司 DNA 的重要组成部分，这真的不是什么大问题。我也认为我们不仅有时差，还有每周工作日的差异。在以色列，我们通常周日至周四工作，而在以色列以外，在大多数国家，我相信
the customers are concerned is almost around the coverage, as far as the customers are concerned, is almost around the clock, which is great. It actually is around the clock, which is fantastic for them. So it's not too bad. If I were on the West Coast, it might be a little bit different. There might not be as much overlap. But with Slack and the internet applications that we have and everything else available for us to communicate. And with knowledge sharing being such a big part of the DNA of the company to begin with, it really isn't that much of an issue. I also think that we don't only have time difference, but also a weekly days difference. In Israel, we usually work Sundays through Thursdays and outside Israel, in most countries, I believe
人们周一至周五工作。所以我们实际上有一天是以色列方面在工作，而其他站点不在，反之亦然。所以我们实际上为此建立了一些仪式。例如，在周日，只有以色列方面在工作。我们通常做一些主要是研发内部的事情，我们部署版本之类的。然后在周五，我们通常让产品人员，他们目前主要位于美国，去查看并创建模型，做其他在研发不完全可用的日子里做起来有意义的事情。是的，这非常有道理。我们的仪式是在周五晚上，我们通常会破坏构建。然后我们在周一早上回来。这似乎是我们过去几周一直遵循的仪式。
people work from Monday through Friday. So we actually have one day where the Israeli side is working and the other sites are not and vice versa. So we actually established a few rituals for that. So for example, on Sundays, where only the Israeli side is working. We usually do stuff that are mostly R&D internal and we deploy versions and stuff like that. And then on Fridays, we usually let product people who are mostly located in the US for now, go over and create mock-ups and do other things that make sense to do on a day where the R&D is not exactly available. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Our ritual is on Friday evening, we typically break the bill. And then we come back on Monday morning. That seems to be the ritual that we've been following for the past few weeks.
但是是的，我认为实际上，你提出了一个非常有趣的点，即关于人们不回办公室的所有讨论。所以我实际上最终，Patrick 和我都最终全职远程工作。我们最终都搬回了我们家人所在的城镇。所以对我们来说，这将是，这是新常态。但即使对于那些回到办公室的人来说，他们中的许多人都在说，我只想一周回三天或两天，或者也许一周工作，一周休息。而那里的挑战是，你知道，当你与一大堆不同的团队一起工作时，你和别人在一起的几率，或者换一种说法，两个整个团队在办公室在一起的几率，
But yeah, I think actually, you bring up a really interesting point that there's all this talk about people not coming back to the office. So I actually ended up, Patrick and I both ended up full-time remote. We ended up both moving back to the towns that our families are in. And so for us, it's going to be, this is a new normal. But even for people who are coming back into the office, a lot of them are saying, I only want to be back three days a week or two days a week, or maybe one week on, one week off. And the challenge there is, you know, when you're working with a whole bunch of different teams, the odds that you and someone else, or maybe put it another way, the odds that two whole teams are in the office together,
即使这些人中没有一个是远程的，也会趋于零，你知道，当我们回到正常状态或任何那是什么，新常态时，两个整个团队在一个房间里的几率趋于零，而以前可能是 50%，对吧？所以我认为这将真正彻底改变。我的意思是，它已经在改变了，但那种革命不会消失，因为我们将永远无法像过去那样亲自安排人们。不，这是一个价值主张，随着时间的推移，Delta 只会变得越来越大。正如人们所经历的那样，即使在疫情期间，当一切基本上都着火了并且很糟糕时，我们都可以同意这一点。
even if none of those people are remote is going to go to zero, you know, when we get back to normal or whatever that is, the new normal, the odds that two whole teams are in a room together goes to zero, whereas before it was maybe 50%, right? And so that I think is going to really revolutionize. I mean, it already is, but that revolution isn't going to go away because we're never going to be able to line up people in person like we used to. No, it's a value proposition and the Delta is only going to get bigger as time goes on. As people have experienced, even during the pandemic when everything is essentially just on fire and horrible, we can all agree to that.
靠近你的家人，能够供养你的家人，能够照顾你家里的老人，能够和你的孩子在一起。远程工作提供的所有这些东西，我认为在疫情期间显示出了巨大的价值。对于那些不为其员工提供全远程安排的公司来说，这种价值，我认为已经超过了薪酬。所以如果人们以一种绝对不必要的方式召回员工回办公室，因为没有办法让人们可持续地做这样的工作，我认为人们会寻找其他工作，因为能够在那里的价值，能够
Being close to your family and being able to provide for your family and being able to give the care to the elderly people in your family, being able to be with your kids. All of the stuff that working remotely provides has shown, I think, significant value during the pandemic. That value, I think, has eclipsed comp for companies that will not offer full remote arrangements for their employees. So if people are recalling employees back to the office in a way that is absolutely not essential, as in there's no way to become remote first enough for people to be able to do jobs like that sustainably, I think people are going to be looking for other jobs because the value of being able to be there, the value of
不再有早晨通勤的价值对他们来说是非常、非常具体的，在 COVID 爆发之前并不是这样。所以我有点偏见，因为我已经做了很长时间了，我无法想象回到以任何其他方式做这件事。我认为在未来，我不会再是少数派了。我认为我们大多数人要么是远程的，要么是某种混合场景。对。我认为对我们来说，混合模式一直运作得很好。
not having that morning commute anymore is very, very tangible to them in a way that wasn't prior to COVID breaking out. So I'm a little bit biased because I've been doing it for a very long time and I can't imagine going back to doing it any other way. I think in the future, I'm not going to be a minority anymore. I think the majority of us are just either going to be remote or some sort of hybrid scenario. Right. I think for us, the hybrid model has been working really well.
而且大多数开发人员现在选择在家工作两天，通常在办公室工作三天。我们只是确保每个人都习惯了这一点。所以我们一直有 Zoom 会议。而且我认为当公司习惯了这种心态时，它就变得自然了
And most of the developers now choose to have two days at home and three days working from the office usually. And we get just to make sure that everyone is used to that. So we have Zoom sessions all the time. And I think when companies get used to that mindset, then it becomes natural
人们也开始看到它的好处。是的，我完全同意。这太棒了。我真的很感谢你们俩分享你们的时间、你们的经历。我觉得我们在这里真的激发了案例，只是为了圆满结束。各位，如果你是一名高中生或大学生，你可能认为为你今天开始的项目写文档没有多大意义，而且明天早上 6 点就要截止了。
and people also get to see the upsides of it. Yeah, I totally agree. This has been amazing. I really appreciate both of you sharing your time, your experiences. And I feel like we've really motivated the case here just to kind of come full circle. Folks out there, if you're a high school or college student, you might think it doesn't make a lot of sense to write documentation for my project that I started today and is due at 6 a.m. tomorrow.
你是对的，但你会遇到一个毕业设计项目。在你毕业之前，你最终会构建更大的系统。这就是你将意识到编写文档的力量的地方。现在把这一点放进你的脑子里真的、真的非常重要。对于行业里的各位，你们可能已经看到了各种各样的文档编写方式。而且你们可能，你知道，只是在点头同意所有这些好坏参半的故事。对于外面的每个人，
And you could be right, but you're going to hit a senior design project. You're going to end up building bigger systems before you graduate. And this is where you're going to realize the power of writing documentation. And it's really, really important to kind of get that into your headspace now. For folks out there who are in the industry, you've probably seen a whole gambit of different ways to do documentation. And you've probably, you know, are just nodding your head at all of these kind of stories, both good and bad. And for everybody out there,
你们一定要去看看这个工具。我今天晚些时候会去看看。听起来它真的闭环了很多东西，并且让它变得容易多了。所以我真的很感谢你们，Omer 和 Tim，都来到节目中谈论并分享你们的经历。哦，很高兴来到这里。是的。非常感谢邀请我们。酷。非常感谢。外面的每个人。非常感谢在 Patreon 上订阅我们。我们
you definitely check out this tool. I'm going to check it out later on today. It sounds like it really closes the loop on a lot of this and kind of makes it a lot easier. So I really appreciate you, Omer and Tim, both coming on the show and talking and sharing your experiences. Oh, it was great to be here. Yeah. Thanks so much for having us. Cool. Thanks a lot. Everybody out there. Thanks so much for subscribing to us on Patreon. We've
已经能够获得一个新的托管服务提供商。所以你可能已经注意到，剧集现在的下载速度比你听它们的速度还要快，这很酷。我的意思是，我们绝对是在那辆花车上迟到了，但通过你们的支持和所有这些，我们已经能够提高我们的产量。所以我想要感谢大家，并帮助让更多的人对节目感兴趣，并对编程感兴趣，
been able to get a new hosting provider. So you might've noticed that the episodes actually download faster than you can listen to them now, which is pretty cool. I mean, we're definitely late on that bandwagon, but through your support and all of that, we've been able to ramp up our production. And so I want to thank everybody for that and helping to get more folks interested in the show and interested in programming,
这是将变得越来越重要的事情。所以谢谢大家，祝你们有愉快的一周。音乐由 Eric Barndaller 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须提供对 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。
which is something that is just going to keep becoming more and more important. So thanks everybody and have a great week. Music by Eric Barndaller Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这只会变得越来越重要。感谢大家，祝大家度过愉快的一周。音乐由 Eric Barndaller 提供。Programming Throwdown 采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播本作品，也可以进行重混或改编，但必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。